Hey, was geht Leute, hallo, herzlich willkommen zur Folge, bevor es gleich losgeht, mit der Live-Folge in Hamburg. Wahrscheinlich denkt ihr jetzt, dass ein technischer Fehler oder so passiert ist und mich davor entschuldigen muss. Nein, andere Sache, es geht gleich los mit der Folge, ich wollte davor nur ganz kurz was in eigener Sache sagen. Und zwar drehen wir nächste Woche Donnerstag am 29.11. für die Netflix-Serie, bei der ich mitgeschrieben habe, eine grosse Szene in Köln. Und da brauchen wir euch für. Es geht um eine grosse Club-Szene und wir haben eine Menge Komparsenrollen zu vergeben. Und ich dachte, wer könnte besser passen als das Podcast-Sofopublikum, wenn es darum geht, einen authentischen Club darzustellen. Und deswegen, wenn ihr darauf Lust habt, mal so einen Tag am Set zu verbringen, es wird wirklich ein langer Tag, aber es gibt Essen und es gibt Trinken. Wenn ihr darauf Lust habt, dann schreibt doch eine Mail an statist.btf.de mit dem Betreff Klubber und schickt am besten auch ein Bild von euch mit.
Also wenn ihr aus Köln und Umgebung kommt und Lust darauf habt, ich schaue auch mal bestimmt kurz vorbei und es ist ein bestimmt lustiger Tag, bei dem man eine Menge sehen kann und sehr viel tanzen muss.
Ich freue mich jedenfalls sehr auf eure Mails und jetzt viel Spaß mit Das Podcast UFO live aus Hamburg. Danke schön! Hey, danke schön! Vielen Dank Hamburg, hallo Stefan, hallo Florenzin, ich grüße dich ganz herzlich. Es war schon Wasser hier. Hallo, was geht Hamburg? Wir haben eine Empore. Schön, sehr schön. Schön, dass ihr da seid. Ich habe Stefan gesagt, es ist nicht die beste Rockstar-Attitüde, wenn man mit einem Sixpack Aldi-Wasser rauskommt. Habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Originalität. Er wollte es einfach mitnehmen. Es ist auch dieses ganz unangenehme Knatschen. Kannst du mal ein bisschen knatschen mit dem Mikrofon? Ja, jeder. Und es ist auch nicht so ganz so clever, weil meistens reißt es ein. Dann hält man es hoch und dann passiert das hier. Und dann fragt man sich, sollen wir es einfach lassen, diese Dinger zu kaufen? Nimm ruhig, ist umsonst. Das erste Souvenir, die sofort fällt die Fassade der Professionalität. Wir können es auch gleich sagen, das hier, das ist nicht ein schwarzes Tuch, das ist eine Monitorbox, Freunde, wir verstecken hier gar nichts für euch. Heute mit runtergelassenen Hosen, wir haben keine Geheimnisse für euch. So ist es. Alter, das war die grosse Finale. Das war unsere grosse Idee für Akt drei. Wie Akt drei. Wenn du diesen Gag jetzt verbrätst, wir haben nichts mehr. Ich habe gemerkt, dass das Flaschending nicht so gut ankam, deswegen dachte ich mir jetzt. Fuck it, einfach. Das ist mir auch aufgefallen. Hey, wie geht's euch Hamburg, seid ihr gut drauf, habt ihr gute Zeit? Sehr gut. Wir machen uns einen schönen Abend, glaube ich. Wir haben vorhin festgestellt, welche die schlechtesten Plätze im Saal sind. Man muss sagen, in Hannover gab es keinen schlechten Platz. Hier gibt es sehr viele schlechte Plätze. Hier gibt es einige gute Plätze, muss man sagen. Es gibt ein paar gute zwischen Geschlechten. Ganz kurz, kann sich mal vielleicht wieder melden, der denkt, er säße auf dem schlechtesten Platz. Ja, sehr gut, sehr nah dran, sehr warm. Ich sehe nur eine Hand, ich sehe nicht mehr das Gesicht. Und das ist, finde ich, da hinten sieht man noch das Gesicht, sorry. Ohne Scheiss, das Theater ist alt, okay, ich verstehe es, I get that, okay. Aber, und es ist noch eine Zeit, wo man noch nicht, wo man sagen muss, okay, wahrscheinlich kannten die sich noch nicht so richtig mit Architektur aus, man war noch nicht so weit, aber Säulen in einem Theater läuten. Ich möchte noch mal sagen, alle die sich gemeldet haben, ihr habt alle recht, ihr sitzt alle auf dem schlechtesten Jahr, genau, und vor allem die, die ich jetzt gerade nicht sehe, ihr sitzt besonders schlecht. Sehr gut, schön, ihr kriegt heute ein extra T-Shirt von Stefan Tietzem. Wir freuen uns sehr, heute hier zu sein in der Leitshalle. Ich glaube, die Presse... Ich hätte mir sagen lassen, es heißt Leischhalle. Wirklich? Es sind alle Vokale drin und ein S und ein Z. Ich glaube, alles ist so ein bisschen richtig. Wahnsinnig viele Vokale. Ich glaube, komplett Polen musste ihre Vokale aufgeben, damit diese Leitshalle überleben kann. Ja, aber die haben sich ja noch so diese Sonderzeichen überlegt, mit dem kaufmännischen und und so, was manchmal im Wort vorkommt, wo man sich fragt, was ist das eigentlich für eine Sprache. Ich möchte mal ganz kurz, weil es gerade um Vokale geht, wir hatten ja mal so ein bisschen von Vorspielabenden mit der Gitarre und da musste man immer sagen, wie das Stück heißt und wie der Komponist heißt. Und das macht man ja normalerweise im normalen Gitarrenunterricht nicht. Frankliszt, Franzliszt, der der erste Vater ist gegangen. Chopin, deswegen weiß man nicht und dann gab es einen und ich dachte mir, gut, das ist jetzt so ein spanischer Name, man kann den jetzt konservativ aussprechen, Juan, man kann aber auch einfach all in gehen und mit einem Sombrero reinkommen und sagen, man kann einfach reingehen und ich habe gesagt, ja hallo, ich bin Florentin Will und ich spiele das Menuet von Juan Buscalia. Und der Musik wird nur so, wow, okay. Aber es hat auch nicht gut funktioniert. Hat nicht gut funktioniert? Wenn man den Namen nicht kennt, sollte man es lassen. Tatsächlich kleiner Funfact zu dieser Halle, hier wurde Kabale und Liebe nur aufgewählt. Wann machst du das? Ist tatsächlich richtig. Schiller, eine der Lieblingshallen von Schiller, er hat, glaube ich, so etwas gesagt wie saugute Akustik. Sau gut, die haben sich den Arsch abgelacht, die Idioten. Das fetzt, haben wir gerade gesagt. Es ist schon wirklich schön, auch mit Säulen und Holz vertäfelt und so weiter. Es heilt sehr, ist es auch aufgefallen, wie so eine Kirche. Wenn ich so einen Balk einen Balkon sehe, den unglaublichen Drang, da so einen Flummi dran zu werfen. Und ich weiss nicht, ob ich so weit kommen würde. Falls jemand einen Flummi dabei hat, bitte, bitte, nein! Das ist eine enorme Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass in einer Menge von 2000 Menschen nicht einer ein Flummi dabei hat. Nein, das ist nicht so eine Zahl, wo man sagt, jeder Hundertste trägt immer einen Flummi bei sich. Gab es nicht Statistiken, gab es nicht da erste Erhebungen letztens von der Tagesschau?
Aber gibt es Wissenschaftler, die sowas mal untersuchen, die sagen so, fuck it, wie viele Leute haben Flummi von tausend?
Bestimmt.
Was würdest du denn, können wir vielleicht selber eine Umfrage machen?
Wir sind hier 650 Leute, wann habt, okay, an welchem, wie machen wir das jetzt?
Wann hat... okay, warte, wir machen das mal... Nee, nee, nee, nee, ich schwöre, ich hab psychische Dürfte.
Okay, okay.
Wer hatte gestern eine Flummi in der Hand?
Na, also da haben wir einen Gewinner!
Zwei Leute, zwei Leute von 650.
Gut, da sind zwei Arme an einer Person, oder?
Ach so, na gut.
Und wer hat letzten Monat schon mal einen Flummi in der Hand?
Die gleiche Person? Na gut, das macht Sinn. Leute, wir haben Zeit, wir ziehen das durch. Wer hat im letzten Jahr einen Flummi in der Hand? Oh, da die rechte Flügel, sehr gut. Der Flummi-Freund ist richtig... Flummi ist irgendwie so weird. Man hat das sehr... Zu einer sehr bestimmten Zeit seines Lebens hat man einen Flummi in der Hand. Danach nicht mehr. Als Erwachsener hast du selten Flummi in der Hand, ausser du machst bei Schlag den Rappen mit oder so, ein bisschen so ein wirrten Spiel. Das stimmt. Ich versuche ja immer, ich glaube, jeder hat so seine eigene Art, die Umwelt wahrzunehmen und damit meine ich vor allem, dass, also zum Beispiel, wenn man aus dem Fenster im Zug guckt, dann gibt es ja so Leute, die stellen sich immer so einen laufenden Menschen daneben vor, der neben dem Zug mitläuft, bestimmt einige hier, sehr, sehr rote, schweißtriefende Gesichter gerade. Sprich mir nicht an, sprich mir nicht an. Die daneben herlaufen und ich habe es immer so mit dem Flummi, dass ich mir immer so einen Flummi vorstelle, der von einem zum anderen springt. Sind Psychologen anwesend? Wow, danke. Dieses Kindheitstraum hast du da nicht überwunden. Ichiss nicht, ob ich so weit werfen könnte. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass du da... Man unterschätzt massiv seine... Also wir sind ja beide extrem unsportlich, was auch dazu führt, dass man seine eigenen... Talk for yourself, man. Dass man seine eigenen Kräfte sehr schlecht einschätzen kann, aber ich habe, glaube ich, bis jetzt jeden einzelnen Wurf meines Lebens nicht geschafft. Ich glaube wirklich jeden einzelnen. Also es gab keinen, wo ich mir dachte so, oh geil, lief gut, alles gut, es ist immer eher so, oh fuck einfach, sorry, irgendwo hin. Aber man muss auch sagen, bei dir hat der Sportlehrer jetzt auch keine Erwartungen gehabt. Ich bin drei Meter achtzig groß, so mit Hebelwirkung und so ein Kram, da sagt der Sportlehrer schon mal, okay, wenn du jetzt genau im 45 Grad Winkel wirfst, kannst du irgendwie den Weltrekord brechen, so und dann läuft er da an und dann ist es peinlich, das ist wesentlich peinlicher als wenn man dir, wenn du da anläufst. So, was erwartet man denn da? Ich wurde noch nie so nett fett genannt, Stefan. Nee. Du schaffst es immer wieder aufs Neue. Du, ich bin jetzt 100 Kilo, Stefan. 100 Kilo, Stefan! Einen Applaus! Das ist wirklich schlimm. 1-0-0. 1-0-0, Stefan. Sehr schön. Ich gehe mit grossen Schritt auf die Tausend jetzt so. Jetzt ist es auch egal. Jetzt muss man sich überlegen, holt man sich eine vierstellige Waage, das ist immer so die Frage. Man denkt, reichen mir die drei Stelle? Ich verstehe Waagen nicht. Wirklich, keine Ahnung. Jetzt hat mir jemand gesagt, ja gut, ich bin auch wenig und weinend in die Firma gelaufen worden, so gesagt, ich bin jetzt 100 Kilo und da hat einer gesagt, ja gut, deine Waage war halt nicht geeicht. Und dann war meine Frage, was?
Geeicht. Und augenscheinlich funktionieren Waagen nicht. Das Gespräch hat sehr lange gedauert und das Ergebnis des Gesprächs war, dass keine Waage funktioniert.
Man kann zu Saturn gehen und den Verkäufer mal wirklich zur Seite nehmen und sagen, hör mal, wie viele Waagen von dir funktionieren eigentlich?
Und der muss dann sagen, nee, die sind alle nicht geeicht. Ich habe selber keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet, aber geh einfach in den Wagenhandel. Und da muss man, weil ich glaube, tatsächlich funktionieren nur die Wagen, die man kennt aus so alten Filmen mit dem Gewicht, wo man links das Kilo hinlegt und rechts dann... Ja, aber woher weiß man, dass das ein Kilo ist? Ja, wer hat das geeicht? Bei mir ist es auch immer so, ich schieße mich auch, hat irgendwelche Wagen verstanden? Vielleicht die auf den schlechten Plätzen, die wir nicht sehen, man weiß nicht, aber ich wieg mich auch immer und dann gibt es immer so den Unterschied zwischen dem ersten und dem zweiten Waaggang und man, ich passte dann halt immer, man versucht, genau eine Chance, so ach komm, einen nehme ich noch und dann tatsächlich zwei oderm weniger. Machst du den Vortaster? Ja klar, natürlich.
Huuuuhuuhu, okay.
Vor allem, ich habe eine Waage, die bezeugt ihre Wagenenergie durch Kraftenergie.
Da muss man draufdrücken und dadurch kriegt die Strom und dadurch geht die erst an und
dann kann man sich draufstellen und dann steht dann da, sagen wir jetzt mal, Beispiel
halber, 160 Kilo vier und dann denkst du dir, na, Beispiel halber, 160 Kilo vier, wenn du denkst dir, nicht ideal, und dann 160 Kilo drei, wenn du denkst dir, Leute, läuft, kein Problem. Bei mir ist die Waage, die ist sehr unsicher, die schwankt. Erst sagt sie 99, dann sagt sie 103 und dann pendelt sie so in der Mitte ein. Aber die ist so sehr sprunghaft. Ich weiß nicht genau, welches Gewicht sie sagen soll. Aber hast du eine, die dich langsam hochpendelt? Weil das finde ich geil, so eine Marco-Schreil-artige, die es noch spannend macht, die immer ein bisschen höher geht. Nach der Werbung kommt das Gewicht. Nach der Werbung. Ich habe eine, die erst runter geht und dann nur noch hoch geht. Also die wirklich, wo du denkst, okay, zwei runter, wie tief kann ich gehen und dann plus eins, plus zwei und irgendwann steht da viertausend Kilo. Arschaufbau. Ich irgendwann runtergehen sollen. Ich weiss nicht, woran es liegt. Was ist das für ein Gerät da eigentlich? Können wir ganz kurz über das grüne Gebilde, was wir vorhin auf der Bühne stehen, sprechen? Ich habe nur vier Staffeln Homeland gesehen, aber ich glaube, das ist eine Bombe. Ja, ich meine, wenn ich eine Bombe bauen würde, ich würde sie genauso aussehen lassen, dass Leute sagen, was ist das, das muss ich mir näher angucken. Auch mit so grünen Klecksen, mit so grünen kinderartigen Klecksen. Ist dir eigentlich mal aufgefallen, Stefan, und das ist mir nämlich aufgefallen, wenn man irgendwas nicht gut sehen kann, ja, ich kenne den Witz, wenn man irgendwas, nee, ist eine Beobachtung, wenn man irgendwas nicht gut sehen kann, ja, und dann denkt man sich, was ist das, was ist das, was kann das sein?
Man kann es nicht sehen.
Wenn man es nicht so gut sehen kann, ja, man ist vielleicht zu weit weg.
Oder zu nah dran.
Oder zu nah dran. Dann Achtung.
Ich lasse dich mal machen.
Dann Achtung, nee, nee, vertrau mir. Dann kneift man ja seine Augen zusammen, obwohl man ja eigentlich mehr sehen will.
Ja, und wenn man da sagt, Dankeschön, das war die Show für heute, vielen Dank! Dankeschön! Und da haben sich die 26 Euro doch gelohnt, kann man sagen, für so eine Beobachtung. Aber ist das nicht verrückt, weil du willst mehr sehen, aber du machst die Augen weiter zu. Die Feuerausgänge sind da hinten übrigens, falls ihr euch das gefragt habt.
Ich habe mir abgeschlossen. Hast du gute Augen eigentlich? Ja, wie gesagt, ich hatte mal, ja, das ist eine doofe Frage, wie man eine Brille trägt, ich lohnte ihn.
Ne, gar nicht, die waren mal ganz gut, die waren mal bei 120%, wie gesagt, wo ich mich mal frage, wer hat die Skala erstellt?
Ja, wurde das geeicht eigentlich mal? Ja, wenn ich, wer hat, warum 120%, warum, die Skala konntet ihr ja selber erstellen. Er stellt sich so, dass ich hundert Prozent habe vielleicht einfach. Jetzt kann sich niemand merken. Ich habe glaube ich jetzt minus zwei Dioptrien. Was geht, glaube ich? Ich glaube also ein Kollege hatte so minus fünf und so, der trägt noch Kontaktlinsen, wo man sich immer fragt, müssen die nicht sehr dick sein, die Kontaktlinsen? Wären die nicht dicker? Man merkt dann irgendwann, wo die Person hinguckt, einfach weil dann immer so ein ganzer Stossglas kommt, so wie bei Bänder. Ich habe sehr schlechte Augen, aber ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich gute oder schlechte Augen habe. Das ist ja so ein bisschen das Ding, man weiß nicht, ob man nicht vielleicht besser sehen sollte. Also woher weiss man das? Woher weiss ein Adler, das ist ganz geil eigentlich, also ist schon nicht schlecht, kann besser sehen als... Woher weiss ein Adler, ob er vielleicht eine Kontaktlinie braucht? Das stimmt. Ab wann sagt man, ich weiss nicht, wovon jemand redet, Adleraugen, ich sehe gar nichts, ich sehe fast nichts. Ist das ein Witz, ist das ironisch gemeint, ist das ein Gag? Ich stürze da runter und dann ist da nichts. Da ist gar nichts. Ich dachte, da wäre eine Maus, da war keine Maus, war nichts. Passiert das oft, glaubst du, dass die Sachen fangen und sich denken, wow, da habe ich komplett daneben gegriffen. Was soll das denn sein, das ist doch gar nichts, Leute. Holy crap, was ist das, eine Zahnbürste? Wie hat man das herausgefunden, was Adler sehen? Hat sich da irgendwer ins Gehirn geschossen? Ja, halt so, ha auch irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, in einem Kilometer Entfernung so eine Vielmann-Tafel angeboten und gesagt, liess mal kurz die erste Reihe vor. Ja, stimmt. Vielleicht, vielleicht auch nicht. Es war einer von den drei Lauten, die er machen kann. Und es war der Richtige. Das stimmt. Er kann uns sehen. Vielleicht haben die auch einfach nur wahnsinnig viel Glück, dass sie einfach immer aus Zufall irgendwas treffen, wo ich mir auch denke, ich kann... Du triffst schon irgendwas, wenn du auf die Seite stürzt. Irgendwas, ja, gibt es da nicht ein Sprichwort, der blinde Adler trifft auch mal einen Korn. Ich glaube, ich habe sehr schlechte Sicht, aber dafür kann ich gut raten. Das ist so mein Vorteil und deswegen glaube ich, würde ich auch jeden Sehtest bestehen, weil ich einfach sehr gut raten kann. Und dann immer so, was steht da, Stuttgart, Hamburg? Ja, Hamburg. Und ich habe einfach gut geraten und es hat einfach bis jetzt jemand es gibt ja es gibt ja so zufall ist ja so prozent zeug so das wissen wir merken wir meinen mathe aber aber an und es ist ja es gibt ja die wahrscheinlichkeit dass einer immer alles richtig macht oder ja wir hören die. Also es gibt ja eine Person auf der Welt, die ausschliesslich Kopf wirft. Oder? Weil bei neun Milliarden Menschen muss ja einer im ganzen Extrem sein von der Normalverteilungskurve, ja das ist ein Wort, Normalverteilungskurve muss einer ganz weit recht sein, der ausschliesslich Kopf wirft und der sein ganzes Leben so, what, was ist denn los hier, Freunde, was ist denn, halt ihr lebt in Peru, niemand weiss von ihm, also fuck, ich hau einen Tweet nach dem anderen raus, aber ich habe zwei Follower und einer davon ist asiatische Weisheiten, die machen gar nichts und ständig einen Kopf nach dem anderen. Es gab mal, und zwar, ich wurde gerade 18 und da haben wir eine Klassenfahrt nach Berlin gemacht, und wir sind erst mal ins Casino gegangen. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, Abi für den Arsch, ist scheißegal, weil in diesem Casino ist mir aufgefallen, da sind halt Leute reingegangen, die hatten sehr, sehr viel Geld. Und da war da dieser eine Tisch, und da konnte man oben sehen, was einen ziemlich wahnsinnig macht, weil oben an diesem Roulett-Tisch gab es halt so eine Liste, was die Vergangenheit des Tisches ist. So von Steuerberatern einfach so, falls sie Schuldner beraten. So eine Liste und da stand dann fünfmal rot und dann sind halt Leute zu diesem Tisch gegangen und haben halt alles auf schwarz gesetzt, was natürlich Bullshit ist, glaube ich, weil es ja immer 50 Prozent, oder? Hast du diese Lektion auf die billige Tour oder auf die teure Tour gelernt, Stefan, 18 Jahre? Nee, und dann kam Mathematik-LK-Stefan, der dann hingegangen ist und hat gesagt, gut, ich mache jetzt 1 Euro auf Rot, so, dann ist die Chance jetzt 50-50, dass es klappt. Wenn es nicht klappt, verdoppel ich und mache wieder auf Rot. Nein, Stefan! Und wenn es klappt, mache ich einen Euro auf Schwarz. So, was ich, ich glaube, es ist im Prinzip clever, wenn du unendlich viel Geld hast. Ja. Dieser Tisch. Lass mich raten, mit achtzehn hattest du nicht unendlich viel Geld. Nee, ich hatte zehn Euro. Okay. Und diese zehn Euro habe ich in Chips, halt in so zwei Euro Chips bekommen. Ja. Und habe halt exakt viermal gespielt und dann war mein Geld halt weg. Und neben mir der war aber ähnlich angefixt wie ich von diesem Tisch, der schon fünfmal rot hatte, wie alle in diesem Casino, wurden langsam unruhig und sind zu diesem Tisch gegangen. Und der hat einfach einen 25.000-Euro-Chip auf die Zahl 36 gelegt. What? Und mir dachte, hallo ganz kurz, ich habe keine Ahnung von Statistik, aber der war gerade fünfmal war der Rot der Tisch. Moment, der legt 35.000 Euro auf die 36. Ja, auf die Zahl 36. Das gibt überhaupt gar nichts. Nee, das ist einfach random. Das ist ein Pferd gerade, das ist ein Pferd im Raum. Ich wollte eigentlich zu Faisal Kawusi, aber jetzt bin ich hier.
Ferdsal Kawusi, nein.
Aber du hast Geld verloren und lass mich raten, der da neben dir saß hat, gesagt, nee, komm, das ist Unglück.
Ich wollte gerade die Anekdote strapazieren und sagen, der Mann mit der 36 hat gewonnen, aber ich glaube, das war nicht so.
Ich habe das auch verloren und ich habe verloren, wir waren alle traurig und ich hätte mir gedacht, warum gibst du mich einfach die 36 Euro. So, das Lachen, was ich dir gebe, das kann dir das Geld, was du da mehr verdienst, nicht geben. Okay, ich wollte tatsächlich auch mal, weil ich jetzt nicht so herablassend auslache, wie so oft, ich habe tatsächlich von dem gleichen Trick auch mal gehört in der Schule und habe demjenigen dann das widerlegt, statistisch, mathematisch, dachte mir, ja, ja auch mal einfach so also wirklich so einerseits ich glaube der mensch einfach dumm egal auch wenn er es verstanden hat macht das trotzdem einfach so zum beispiel kleine anekdote aus meinem alltagsleben ich war heute einkaufen und wollte so einen schönen joghurt mir holen schöner joghurt und dann so recht schön kirschj so, du denkst so, wie kriegen die das so kirschig, was sind das für Kirschen?
Und ich wollte den kaufen und direkt essen. Kaufen, nach Hause, essen. Kaufen, zahlen, einpacken, laufen, auspacken, essen, aus.
Okay, haben das alle verstanden hier? So, jetzt stand aber drauf, 50% reduziert, nur noch kurze Haltbarkeit.
So, ich dachte mir... Aber das passt genau in deinen Plan.
Ich dachte mir, kurze Haltbarkeit, einpacken, zahlen, nach Hause laufen, auspacken, essen, ist recht kurz.
Dafür halben Preis, Kirschen, einpacken? Zahlen? Nach Hause? Nee, lieber nicht. Ich habe den Normalen genommen, der doppelt so viel kostet. Einfach weil ich mir dachte, fuck it, das ist mir zu riskant. Obwohl ich genau wusste, du bist der dümmste Mensch der Welt. Ich saß da und sie meinte so 1,80 Euro und ich so, das könnten auch 1,20 Euro sein. Ich habe mein Mathe-Studium nicht abgeschlossen. Das könnten auch 1,20 Euro sein und dachte mir einfach, aber man ist einfach so dumm, man hat bei dem Wort reduzierte Haltbarkeit direkt schon so Maden im Kopf und so, so Kirschmaden, so eine Maden, so ein Mö. Ja, diese ganzen Märkte sind so aufgebaut, dass du versagst einfach. Allein, also okay, können wir ganz kurz nochmal den Wirtschaftsexperten Stefan Tietze fragen, die ganzen Märkte sind so aufgebaut, dass du versagst einfach. Okay, können wir ganz kurz noch mal den Wirtschaftsexperten Stefan Tietze sagen, die ganzen Märkte sind so aufgebaut, dass du versagst. Supermärkte, die sind nämlich dir voraus. Allein es fängt ja schon mal so an, dass alle Supermärkte linksrum aufgebaut sind, dass man linksrum gehen muss, wo ich mich schon total wohlfühle. Ich bin linksrumgeher, ich komme rein in den Markt und es ist gegen den Uhrzeigersinn.
Und ich sage mir, ja, genau so fühle ich mich wohl. Weil Leute herausgefunden haben, das sind eben die gleichen Wissenschaftler, die herausgefunden haben, dass einer von tausend Leuten immer einen Flummi bei sich hat,
die haben mich auch herausgefunden, dass Menschen immer links herum gehen, lieber als rechts herum. Diesen Versuch würde ich auch mal gerne sehen, übrigens.
Und die haben herausgefunden, dass es so ist und deswegen sind Supermärkte immer linksrumgebaut oder nicht kennt ihr einen supermarkt der rechts rum aufgebaut ist nein alle rufen rein alle rufen alle haben schon mal einen gesehen ja aber geht ihr da gerne einkaufen ja also also naja das ist zum einen dann der augenhöhe trick. Die teuersten Sachen sind immer auf Augenhöhe, weil wir uns nicht gerne bücken. Deswegen ist es gut, dass ich größer bin, weil dann ist direkt die Bündigste immer auf Augenhöhe oder die Sachen, die schon abgelaufen sind. Aber ich glaube, merkt die sind uns da voraus. Ich glaube auch, ja. Aber ich bin einfach dumm. Und ich wusste auch da, es ist wirklich so, ich habe so zwei Stimmen in meinem Kopf, die eine ist super schlau und die andere hat recht.
Das ist einfach so, ich weiß, dass das falsch ist, aber ich mache es trotzdem. Und genau so war es auch bei diesem Trick, aber das war ja damals, das war irgendwie 2001 oder so, ich sag einfach mal was.
Damals 2001. Ich sag einfach mal was. Und dann musste man aber als Schüler, dann war das nicht so leicht, Online-Casino zu spielen, weil man musste sich erst irgendeine besondere Karte kaufen, so eine Geldkarte, mit der man auch Sachen gut haben, ausladen kann. Das beruhigt mich irgendwie. Es war nicht so leicht, als Schüler im Online-Casino zu spielen. Und direkt habe ich so ein wohliges Gefühl, in Deutschland funktioniert einiges, ganz gut. Damals hat es gut funktioniert. Da musste ich irgendwo zehn Euro herbekommen, dann musste ich da mit so einem Automaten, wo man so Guthabenkarten für Handys kaufen konnte, da musste ich dann irgendwie, da habe ich dann keinen Ausweis gebraucht. Und das konnte ich dann wiederum auf irgendeiner Seite einzahlen, wo ich ein Guthaben hatte, dass ich wieder überweisen konnte auf die Kino. Wie wohl Maria gesagt hat, wenn du das Feld des Bauern von fünf Wölfen befreist, dann kriegst du das du suchst. Ich kann es nur zweimal hin und her fahren. Ich habe einen Wolf, Körner und einen Frosch. Und ich habe das gemacht, ich habe die Karte gekauft, eingezahlt, überwiesen und während der gesamten Zeit lief der Ocean's Eleven Soundtrack. Das könnt ihr aber darauf wetten, Freunde. Während ich meine Zahl eingetippt habe, lief der Ocean's Eleven Soundtrack. Aber sowas von. Ich war, glaube ich, noch nie so kriminell während dem Tag, als ich natürlich innerhalb von kürzester Zeit mein gesamtes Geld verloren habe. Übrigens, also man muss sagen, wir versuchen diesen Abend irgendwie als Event hinzubekommen. Stefan wird noch über den Stuhl springen heute Abend? Vielleicht noch, wenn es nicht gut läuft. Und deswegen dachten wir uns, wir geben uns Mühe mit der Einlassmusik. Weil plötzlich vor der ersten Show, weiß ich nicht mehr, wo das war, in Berlin glaube ich damals, dieses Jahr war das glaube ich noch, im März, keine Ahnung, kein Gedächtnis, da haben wir dann plötzlich, wurden wir vor die merkwürdige Aufgabe gestellt, eine Einlassmusik zu machen. Was macht man da? Und dann haben wir uns wirklich Mühe gegeben und niemand hat es irgendwie angesprochen. Weil da dachten wir auch, wie wäre es, wenn wir den Oceans Eleven Soundtrack machen und alle sitzen so mit zu schlitzen geformten Augen im Publikum und sagen, jetzt habe ich richtig Bock. Alles lief nach Plan. Aber hat niemand angesprochen. Was sich oft macht, wenn ich den Oceans... Ich höre sehr oft den Oceans Soundtrack. Ich auch, tatsächlich. Und was ich mache, ich laufe durch die Strasse und ich gebe Leuten so Signale. So wie in dem Film, wo die sich dann so die Brillen runternehmen und dann wissen alle und ich laufe auch mal so weiter und so. Und dann denke ich immer, dass die Person weitergeht und dann irgendwie so so zu der nächsten Person und die dann so zack und dann gibt es so eine Kindreaktion. Und dann lässt jemand in den Luftballon steigen und du stellst die Tasche ab und gehst. Ja genau, und dann wirft so ein Kind ins Wasser und der weiss, okay jetzt geht's los, das war das Signal. Passiert nicht, die meisten so, bitte? Nee, es passiert gar nichts. Aber die Kopfhörer sagt, nee nee, sorry. Aber das Problem ist ja, dass du im Alltag nicht wegschneiden kannst. Im Film schneidest du immer dann weiter und dann wird's cool so. Das ist immer so der, dann schneidest du irgendwo was cooles. Ja, dann kannst du dich wegschneiden.
Im Alltag nicht, da bist du dann immer so in der langweiligen Storyline, dass denn der Einbrecher kommt, wirft die Granate, Rauch ist weg, die Einbrecher sind weg, aber du bist immer noch im Laden. Und dann guckst du halt immer noch so, kann ich jetzt noch zahlen? Ist das jetzt nur, weil jetzt eine Rauchgranate war? Was sind die Regeln? Weisst du, so ein Filialleiter von Edeka, weisst der, wenn jetzt hier eine Rauchgranate hochgeht, dann bitte höflich die Leute zu gehen oder kassier noch ab. Wer da in der Kasse steht, müssen die selber ihre Waren zurücklegen oder wird es für die gemacht? Wissen die das? Solche Situationen sind weird. Auch, habe ich auch gesagt, als ich jetzt nach Mexiko geflogen bin, wo ich dachte, wenn jetzt ein Flugzeug irgendwo von einer Landebahn abkommt, und dann ist klar, das ist halt schlecht für die Insassen und für den Flughafen. Wusstest du nicht, dass du Flugexperte bist? Nee, aber tatsächlich kann ja die andere Landebahn, da könnte ja auch jemand starren. Du meinst, wenn jetzt einer wirklich abstürzt, oder was? Ja, dann ist da halt Trümmer, dann ist die Feuerwehr halt da. Aber warum muss der Mainflieger jetzt warten? Weil es gibt ja mehrere, ich verstehe das Problem, Start- und Landebahn. Ja, ja. Eine Durchsage vom Kapitän, Sie haben gerade gesehen, dass das Flugzeug neben uns mit vielen brennenden Leichen zu Boden gegangen ist, der Verlust wird auf ungefähr hundert Leben gerechnet.
Trotzdem jetzt weiterhin viel Spaß mit unserem Film für die Reise Oceans 12.
Was für ein Kracher und gleich geht's auch los, noch eine Runde rückwärts.
Ich glaube, man würde einfach weiter fliegen, oder?
Ja, stimmt schon.
Ich frage mich, warum das wird ja nicht gemacht, klar sind da alle schlecht drauf, aber dann zeigst du halt die Incredibles 2 und dann ist doch gut. Als Ausgleich für die vier verbrannten Kinder, die ihr gerade gesehen habt, Incredibles 2. Ja, oder dann geht halt die Stewardess so durch und macht halt die Sonnenblenden runter, wo man sagt, okay, das Problem ist gelöst, wir starten einfach von L3, niemand weiß, was L3 ist, und dann kann man da halt starten und ist man pünktlich im Urlaub. So, und da kann man sich ja erholen von dem Schrecken, den man hatte. Ich meine, das stimmt schon. Ich bin auch wirklich, glaube ich, der schlechteste Autofahrer der Welt, was so Notarzt-Situationen angeht und so Polizei und so, weil ich nie weiß, was los ist und ich auch immer in so ein ... Ich krieg zu viel Panik und dann ich überkompensiere.
Manchmal wünsche ich mir, dass mein Leben aufregender ist als es ist und wenn ich Sirenen hinter mir höre, denke ich manchmal so ein bisschen, die wollen mich, die sind hinter mir her, scheiße, die wissen, dass ich auf der Podcast-Ufo-Seite nicht so ein Disclaimer für irgendwelche Cookies oder irgendein Kram gemacht habe. Erpressung, wofür braucht man das? Man muss eine Telefonnummer angeben, haben wir nicht, unsere funktioniert nicht.
Keine Ahnung, die istGV, die haben mich jetzt. Und dann denke ich mir so, komm, jetzt gib Gas einfach, jetzt fahr, jetzt fahr einfach ab nach Mexiko. Aber das Beste ist ja, Leute bilden ja die Rettungsgasse. Ja, ich nicht. Wo man sagt, wenn die Polizei kommt, bilden Leute eine Rettungsgasse. Ich nutze die Rettungsgasse. Ich finde das nicht gut. Genau, ich finde das nicht gut, weil Leute, die fliehen wollen bei der Verfolgungsjagd, die haben den optimalen Fluchtweg.
Guter Punkt, guter Punkt. Deswegen Leute, immer auf die Rettungsgasse verzichten, lieber schön in den Weg stellen.
Und wenn ihr seht, dass eine Rettungsgasse vorliegt, dann direkt reinstellen, damit der Verbrecher nicht da vorbekommen.
Damit ich fliehen kann. So, wir machen doch Fortschritte heute, ist doch gut.
Aber mir war es wirklich katastrophal, vor allem, ich habe immer die Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer, oh verhaftet mich, oh, 83 Euro, wenn man mal eben so raushauen, weil die Karte 26 Euro kostet. Ne, ich glaube eher, weil es verboten ist, im Strassefagetti zu tragen, deswegen meine ich. Das war jetzt, als ich gesagt habe, bitte verhaftet mich, das war sarkastisch, bitte, ernsthaft, bitte sagt das niemandem. Und deswegen höre ich immer nicht, von wo die Sirenen kommen, wahrscheinlich ist es deswegen auch verboten, deswegen höre ich immer nicht, wovon die Sirenen kommen und denke dann immer, ach, das würde mich schon nicht betreffen.
Und dann irgendwann stehen die direkt hinter mir und letztens musste ich wirklich auf so eine Ampelinsel fahren, wo so da war so Ampel und dann so Kinderwagen und zwei Rentner und ich so, ja sorry, Leute, ich muss jetzt hier durch und stand Mitte auf der Insel, weil wirklich auch, das waren anscheinend so so so kriminalpolizei autos so normale autos mit der mit dem mit dem mit der eiskugel oben drauf und dann also die kürzler autos die überhaupt und dann wirklich aber fünf stück und alle haben gehupt und ich denke mir fuck it ich muss jetzt irgendwas machen und während es noch gegenverkehr ins kind reingefahren dachte ich mir einfach sorry kind einfach das sind die sachen die man dann im Tatort nicht sieht, wer dann alles nebenbei stirbt, dachte mir jetzt, fuck it, ich muss jetzt, so, und dann fahre ich auf diese Insel, wirklich hängen da so zwischen zwei Bürgersteigen obendrauf irgendwie, hingen drin, so der Kinderwagen direkt auf Augenhöhe mit dem Kind im Kinderwagen, und das Kind denkt sich, kommt schon ernsthaft, er sagt, aber mit einem Car to go smart gegen Kinderwagen gewinnt, glaube ich, den Kinderwagen. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Und dann wirklich ziehen das wirklich sieben Autos an mir vorbei, alle hupen, es war irgendwie ein krasses, krasses Ding. Cool. Vielleicht, keine Ahnung. Nee, meine Cousine hatte mal einen Unfall mit einem Krankenwagen. Oh nein. Aber auch einen relativ Unfall, wo man sagt, okay, da müsste man jetzt mal aussteigen und gucken, wie es meiner Cousine geht.
Aber ich habe bis heute nicht gefragt, was ich mich... Wow, wow, wow! What the fuck, das Ding findet anzusprechen. Es ist unfassbar gruselig. Sollten wir uns jetzt Angst... Könnte halt auch eine Bombe sein, Freunde. Hat irgendwer von euch das dahingestellt? Steht das?
Ich weiss nicht, wann der Zeitpunkt ist, Wundveranstalter einschreiten soll.
Das ist für mich das erste Mal, dass sowas passiert.
Ist das, glaube ich, einfach ein Wecker oder wie man muss oben drauf?
Holy shit, Jesus.
Haben wir Bombenexperten? Ich wusste, dass es irgendwann passiert, dass irgendein Hörer Gags macht. Aber ganz kurz wirklich, ist es von euch? Jesus, Leute! Es können nicht alle Veranstalter mit den Schultern so. Sorry, ich hab ne Bombe, hallo, ich hab ne Bombe entschärft! Was hat ihr denn was ich... Was ist das denn für ein Gerät? Ey Leute, das war von Chibo. Was ist das von Chibo? Vielleicht schlechteste Product Placement aller Zeiten. Chibo.de! Ich dachte gerade, ich habe das Konzept von Chibo verstanden. So, okay, die haben Luftmatratzen, die haben so ein Heizdecken und das, was ist das denn? Leute, aber kommt schon, ich habe eine Bombe entschärft, da kommt gar nichts, wirklich im Ernst, ich dachte, das ist so der eine Heldenmoment, von dem man sein Leben lang träumt, so irgendwie, ah, fällt ein Kind ins Wasser und man fängt es noch auf oder so und dann auch die Leute so, ne muss schon was kommen ich richtig enttäuscht aber
gut hat irgendwie ohne scheiß das mal hat irgendwann eine ahnung was das ist bitte es fliegt da raus ja okay ich habe die bombe kaputt gemacht habe ich die bombe kaputt gemacht Oh, der Böse floh und die hat die Bombe kaputt gemacht.
Jaja.
Okay, gut. Hat euch die Playlist gefallen? Habe euch die Einlassmusik gefallen? Nein, enttäuschtes Kopfschütteln. Nein, wir hatten immer, wir dachten uns, irgendwie eine eigene Playlist oder eine Folge Gäste, Liste Geisterbahn. Wir wissen es noch nicht genau zum Einlass. Ja, also ich dachte ja wirklich, und da muss man sagen, war Florentin gegen, ich wollte fünfzig Mal den gleichen Song. Und ich hab mich gefragt, weil beim ersten Mal sagen die Leute, okay, wirken mit, beim zweiten Mal sagen die Leute, okay, der Song ist lang, beim dritten Mal sagen die Leute, okay, der lief jetzt schon wieder. Wann fangen Leute an, rauszugehen plötzlich? Ich weiss es nicht, keine Ahnung.
Bei Einlassmusik.
Sorry, ganz kurz, du hast gerade so enttäuscht deinen Kopf geschüttelt.
Nee, nee, ich schaue schon dich an, Fräulein.
Welche Musik würdest du denn gerne hören?
Welche, hallo, ich rede mit Ihnen.
Welche Musik würden Sie denn gerne hören?
Aha, plötzlich ganz leise, plötzlich ganz leise, unzufrieden sein, aber keine Lösung anbieten. Das sind die, die bei der Party sagen, scheiss Musik, scheiss Playlist, mach mal eine andere Playlist an. Und der DJ, ja was denn, stattdessen, was denn? Glaubst du, wäre ich als DJ, konstant nervös, ist es okay, ist die Musik, ist es alles okay, ist es tanzen oder ein Schlaganfall, ist es okay, was machst du? Ich weiß, ich habe extrem geringes Vertrauen in meinen Musikgeschmack, wirklich gar keinen, hast du recht. Als ich das erste Mal mitbekommen habe, dass man bei Spotify sehen kann, was andere so hören, das war der schlimmste Tag meines Lebens.
Holy fuck, ohne Scheiss, Spotify gibt einen Scheiss auf Datenschutzrichtlinien und so. Wenn ihr Kontakte habt bei Spotify, guckt mal, ihr könnt komplett sehen, was die hören. Und bei mir war das ganze Profil öffentlich. Und ich habe peinliche Playlists, ich habe Musical-Playlists, peinliche fucking, ja gut, wir sind in Hamburg, deswegen, Leute waren begeistert, aber das konnten Leute sehen, und meine Shazam-Playlist auch, und da hat jemand gesagt, wann hast du Faith von George Michael, Shazam, jeder kennt das Lied, und es ist nicht das Lied, wo man rumläuft und sagt, ich muss jetzt einen Song hören. Ich muss jetzt einen Song hören. Vor allem auch in der Öffentlichkeit. Aber vor allem, dann hat man ja so diese, man kann ja dann auch hören, was andere Leute hören, und man kann wiederum sehen, wie viele Leute dir zuhören, und dann gucke ich da halt mal so drei Leute listening, und dann einfach so, okay, danke Spotify, dafür. Du kannst,, ah du hast diese Live-Funktion angemacht, wo man hört, was du gerade hören kannst. Ich habe aktiv nichts angemacht, aber es ist so, dass du dann draufklicken kannst und hörst du das. Er spult schon wieder zurück zum Anfang des Refragens von Any Only Time. Nochmal Eternal Flame zum siebten Mal heute und ich hatte wirklich so drei People listening und ich dachte mir, danke Spotify, dass sie mich zu dem schlechtesten DJ der Welt macht gerade. Für diese drei Armen verlorenen Seelen. Für dreimal Spotify Premium Werbung nacheinander. Das ist übrigens... Dürfen wir noch Schlechtes über Spotify sagen? Ich weiß es nicht. Das Spotify-Maskottchen sitzt da drüben. Spotinchen, das Spotify-Maskottchen. Ach ja, Hamburg, ey.
Wahnsinn.
Hamburg ist schon irre. Aber ganz kurz, weil du gesagt hast, du bist geflogen. Kleiner, wir müssen ganz kurz mal in die Rubrik gehen. Okay, gut. Seid ihr bereit? die Podcast-Ufo-Entschuldigung. Okay, das war eine Frage der Zeit. Stefan hat letzte Woche von seinem Urlaub erzählt, für alle die es nicht wissen, er war in Maya und hat eine Sportart der Maya entdeckt. Das stimmt. Und hat von einer mysteriösen, also von Geheimnissen durchdrungenen Sportart erzählt. Er war der erste Mensch, der jemals Augen auf diese merkwürdigen Sportgeräte geworfen hat. Niemand hat jemals weisst, wie das gespielt wurde.
Es handelt sich um zwei steinerne Körbe, die an Wänden hängen mit einem Spielfeld dazwischen.
Und er meinte, dass der normale Guide gar nicht wusste, was das ist.
Und nur der eingeborene Guide, mit dem nur Stefan gesprochen hat, nur der wusste, was es mit dieser mysteriösen Sportart überhaupt auf sich hat. Und Stefan hat dieses geheime Wissen natürlich mit der Podcast-Ufo-Gemeinde geteilt. Er hat das in die Welt hinausgeschickt und gesagt, Leute, guck es, wie diese Sportart denn gespielt wird, stellt sich raus.
Genau diese Sportart wurde auch in dem sehr beliebten Disney-Film Ein Königreich für ein Lama, das 160 Millionen Menschen gesehen haben, auch vorgestellt, Stefan! an! Ja, aber dann, ich habe den, ja, das ist ein Applaus des Charms, das ist der Charme-Applaus. Ich habe, ja, vielen Dank an die vielen fucking Mails, die ich bekommen habe. Ich habe mir dann die Szene auch nochmal geguckt und okay, es ist exakt das Spiel, was sie da in diesem Einenbten Disney-Pixar-Film ... Disney-Pixar-Film, den haben wir vier, fünf Leute gesehen, also wahrscheinlich nur eingeborene Leute, haben sich dann irgendwie so aus Blättern im Dschungel, haben sich so einen Fernseher gebaut und konnten dann durch die Anrufung der alten Götter diesen Disney-Film sehen. Das waren nur ganz wenige, oder? Nicht, aber das, also gut, vielleicht habe ich ein bisschen übertrieben, aber es lief wirklich ein Guide rum, der deutsch gesprochen hat und laut gesagt hat, wir wissen nicht, was
sie hier spielen.
Das ist kein Scherz.
Und ich frage mich, als ich dann so viele Nachrichten bekommen habe, dachte ich mir,
wie reagiert der, wenn man irgendwann in seiner Truppe sagt, oh, ist doch das wie
ein Königreich von Lama.
Und er so sagt, was?
Was?
Und dann zeigen sie mal ihre Zertifikation.
Und dann rennt er weg.
Vielen Dank. so das wie ein Königreicher Programm. Und er so sagt, was? Und dann zeigen sie mal ihre Zertifikation und dann rennt er weg. Gibt es eigentlich den Job des Reiseführer-Prüfers? So wie ein Fahrlehrer, der halt dann so, was eine Führung durch Münster, wie interessant, ich komme mal mit. Und dann wirklich bei jedem Fakt einfach so dann so, nicht gewusst, nicht gewusst, wann, was wurde in Münster-Uhr aufgeführt, aha, okay, okay. Kabal und Liebe weg. Und am Ende der Führung dann so, guten Tag Heinrichsen von der Reiseführer-Kooperation, Sie haben den Test nicht bestanden, raus. Ich habe kein Vertrauen in Reiseführer, gar kein Vertrauen. Vor allem seit Google Maps und so. Also du kannst einfach drauf gucken, was das für ein Gebäude ist. Und dann kannst du auf Wikipedia gucken und sagen, das ist aber Neoklassizismus. Es gibt doch immer einen in der Reisegruppe, der auch noch nebenbei Wikipedia auf hat, oder? Vor allem, ich meine, der erste Reiseführer der Welt war doch einfach ein Typ, der einfach ein bisschen zu viel geredet hat. Oder der einfach so, alter, heiß. Und zu oft an diesem Ort war. Ja, zu oft einfach an dem Ort war, bis sich Leute einfach da eingefunden haben und sich gedacht haben, okay, ich höre dem zu. Und irgendwann wurde er dann gejagt, weil er irgendwie Christ war oder was auch immer. Und dann ist er durch die Stadt gelaufen und dann sind die Leute ihm hinterher gelaufen. Und so ist das entstanden. Ja, aber ich habe gestern eine Doku geguckt über Nordkorea, es war wieder so ein YouTube-Abend, jeder kennt ihn doch, jeder hat diesen YouTube-Abend, wo man ein bisschen zu lang vom YouTube hängt und dann so eine Abwärtsspirale und man hat in diesen angebotenen Videos rechts, ist immer diese eine Nordkorea-Doku, oder nicht? Ja, die wir alle auch schon lange vor uns vorschieben. Und jeder hat sich schon genau vor sich hingeschoben und irgendwann sagt man, okay, es ist ja nicht so weit. Alles gut? Ja, alles gut. Wo man dann auch wahrscheinlich irgendwie dann, als dann irgendwie Deutschland befreit wurde von den Alliierten und alle gesagt haben, ich wusste von nichts, die haben einfach die Doku nicht gesehen, die haben einfach die Doku so lange vor sich her geschoben. Und wenn jetzt Nordkorea irgendwie dann Stress macht, wir auch alle so, wir wussten von nichts, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe die Doku, ich habe das Tab offen, ich habe den Tab offen, ich will sie gucken, sie ist zur Hilfe geladen, aber ich habe einfach noch keine Zeit gehabt, die Doku zu gucken. Und tatsächlich hat Nordkorea auch, wenn man da Urlaub macht, und jedes Jahr machen 5000 Leute in Nordkorea Urlaub, und du kommst dann da hin und dann wirst du in so einen Bus gesetzt mit einer Fremdenführerin, die nicht halt durch das Land fährt. Und du darfst nicht mit den Leuten da sprechen. Und wenn du dich falsch verhältst, dann kannst du einfach in den Knast kommen. Und da war da einfach so ein US-Student, der dann mit diesem Bus rumgereist ist und glaube ich ein Plakat oder so aufhängen wollte, was die Leute warnt, dass sie in einer fucking Diktatur leben, wo alles schlecht ist. Wow, sorry, 2018 und seine Entscheidung ein Plakat. Das ist seine Idee. So, ich werde die Welt verändern mit Macht eines Plakats.
Plakate, die bis jetzt noch nichts erreicht haben in dieser Welt. Die fünf Leute erreichen, bevor es
abgerissen wird. Ja, wobei wir verkaufen Plakate. Ach übrigens, falls ihr nach der Show noch ein
Plakat kaufen wollt. Das ist ein Poster. Das ist kein Plakat. Der war zwei Jahre im Gefängnis da. Der hat niemanden rausgeholt, weil er das Plakat aufgehangen hat. Und trotzdem machen immer noch 5000 Leute da jedes Jahr Urlaub. Weil die dachten, ja, mir wird wahrscheinlich nichts passieren, ich gehe einfach mal hin. Und das ist wirklich fantastisch gewesen, diese Doku, weil die planen einfach diesen Trip für dich. und der ist ganz, ganz sorgfältig so geplant, dass du niemanden triffst, der in diesem Land lebt. Und dann werden die auf dem Bauernhof geführt und da sind keine Bauern, weil die darfst du halt nicht treffen. Und dann fragt man sowas wie, ja warum, das ist eigentlich ganz lustig, deswegen würde ich da auch gerne im Urlaub machen, dann kannst du halt, du darfst halt kritische Fragen stellen, aber nicht so kritisch. Und die müssen dann improvisieren, warum das gerade so ist, wie es ist. Zum Beispiel, warum sind denn hier gerade keine Bauern? Und dann kannst du, dann siehst du in dem Gesicht, rattert es dann so ein bisschen. Ja, weil es gerade zu heiß ist. Die sind gerade alle, und die müssen sich halt immer ausredend überlegen. Die sind gerade alle im Swimmingpool. Ach, wo ist der Swimmingpool? Der ist verdampft, weil es so warm ist und dann der Dampf ist. Ist die immer so heiß? Ist die immer so heiß? Ist die oft so heiß? Nein, normalerweise ist es sehr angenehm hier, aber nur gerade jetzt sehr heiß. Und bei den Dratter ist es dann halt immer so. Und ich bin ganz faszinierend, weil die dann eine Station ist halt so ein Museum, wo offensichtlich haben die sich, jetzt will ich mich aus dem Fenster lehnen, aber die haben sich einen Massaker ausgedacht von den Amerikanern. Sagt die Doku so ein bisschen. Es hat niemand herausgefunden, ob es dieses Massaker wirklich gab, aber die haben halt so ein Riesenmuseum aufgebaut, wo man halt, was halt wirklich einfach furchtbar ist und wo die gesagt haben, und dann, ich stelle mir das vor, weil die Doku sagt, das haben die sich ausgedacht. Ich will mich jetzt, wie gesagt, echt nicht so weit aus dem Fenster lehnen, vielleicht gab es das wirklich und ich leugne gerade irgendeine Form von nordkoreanischen Holocaust. Ich versuche es trotzdem mal, ich gehe mal all in.
Trau dich, wenn das dein Kalenderspruch nicht sagt, trau dich einfach mal irgendeinen Massenvernichtungskrieg zu leugnen. Weil wenn das wirklich passiert ist, hat sich irgendwer in Nordkorea ausgedacht Folgendes, ja dann haben die Amerikaner unsere Babys genommen, haben eine Schnur drum gewickelt und es dann als Fussball benutzt.
Das sind so Wandgemälde von solchen Situationen. Man denkt sich, bitte, was haben die gemacht? Das ist ein heftiges, heftiges Kriegsverbrechen. Wo haben die die ganzen Babys her? Wo haben die die ganzen Babys her? Die haben den Frauen die Brüste abgeschnitten und die dann gegessen. Und man sagt, okay, irgendwer muss sich das offensichtlich ausgedacht haben, wenn das nicht stimmt. Was es vielleicht tut oder vielleicht auch nicht. Aber das fand ich ganz gruselig. Und danach hat dann diese Fremdenführerin, ist er mit dem Bus weitergefahren und dann hat dieser Typ, der die Dokumentation spricht, hat dann gesagt, und dann wollte die Fremdenführerin uns wieder auflockern, die Stimmung ein bisschen auflockern. Und man sagt, warum plant ihr das als Ziel ein, wenn ihr euer Land gut darstellen wollt und 5000 Leute jährlich euch besuchen, das ist was nicht so viel ist. So macht man einen Strand auf oder einen Skiresort oder so und führt ihn nicht in euer scheiß Museum, wo Kinder als Ballbälle benutzt werden und wo ihr danach gute Laune machen müsst. Und dann hat man auch gesehen, dass der Humor nicht so wirklich weit ist in Nordkorea, weil dann war ihr großer Witz, den sie mehrmals wiederholt hat, weil es hat dann geregnet, als sie rausgefahren sind. Oh, der Himmel weint, weil das gerade so traurig war, sagt dann die Fremdschwürgerin. Und der ganze Bus ist so still und dann hat sie das Gefühl, das hat der Bus gerade nicht verstanden und sie wiederholt das und man denkt, holy fucking shit, ey, vielleicht soll ich da einfach Urlaub machen, um der Frauen ein gutes Gefühl zu geben. Ja, oder wenn deine Standardkarriere irgendwo blüht, dann in Nordkorea. Oder nicht? Das kriegst du auch noch hin. Ja. Wahnsinn, warum eine Schnur? Also warum deine Schnur kann als Bäck? Das war der Fakt, wo du noch mal nachhagen würdest. Widerspricht sich das nicht? Aber da gibt es ja auch so die Legende, die machen ja ihren Führer immer total gross und Propaganda, was er alles kann. Und dann wurde irgendein Golfplatz eingeweiht mit 18 Löchern und der erste, der auf diesem Golfplatz spielt, war er selber. Und dann war die offizielle Staatsnachricht, er hat den Kurs abgeschlossen mit wie vielen Schlägen? 17. Ne, mit 19. Oh, what the fuck? Also einfach so bei einem ist ihm irgendwie kurz die Brille runtergefallen oder so, aber ansonsten perfekt. Jeden mit einem nur einmal irgendwie da, er ist mit der Schläger ausgerutscht, aber er ist einfach damit es glaubwürdiger ist. Und was diese Doku auch gesagt hat, was für mich auch mein Blowing war, war, dass der spricht fliessend deutsch, weil Kim Jong-un ist aufgewachsen, nicht aufgewachsen, aber er hat zwei Jahre in der Schweiz gelebt. Ja, ja, Schweiz. Ja, ja, deswegen hat er auch, man hört es ein bisschen raus, wenn man Nordkoreisch kann, diesen Hauch Schweiz einfach so ein bisschen. Und dann haben die einen Schulfreund von dem interviewt, der war in der Klasse mit Kim Jong-Un. Die kannten den unter anderem anderen Namen, aber stell dir das mal vor, und er war ein riesen Basketballfan, er war immer bei dir zuhause und die waren einfach Freunde und er konnte fliessendeutsch und dann stell dir mal vor, dann war der nach zwei Jahren wieder nach Nordkorea und der Freund sitzt dann irgendwann abends vorm Fernseher und Sepp durch und irgendwann so, what, Michel, was, das ist dann einfach, der Schulfreund sitzt dann vor so einem Riesensaal, wo Leute zujubeln, mit so einem Atomknopf. Ja. Scheiße. Sag mal, Paul, hast du eigentlich noch irgendwie so alte peinliche Schulfotos, so Gruppenfotos oder sowas? Komm, jetzt zeig mal, zeig mal einmal her. What the fuck? Das ist Bin Laden, Hitler und Mao auf einem Bild, ja war ein verrücktes Jahr. My crazy college hier. Wie interessant, der konnte fließendeutsch, der war wesentlich, und dann hat er immer zwei Leute gehabt, die hinter ihm hergelaufen sind. Und die haben halt irgendwann gedacht, die sind einfach Verwandte, weirde Verwandte, die hinter dem herlaufen. Und dann haben sich halt im Nachhinein erschlossen, dass es einfach Leibwächter waren, die halt wollten, dass er eine gute Bildung bekommt. alles dass dieses dynastien da hingeschickt die schweiz hat ihn das war ja auch die schule gehen lassen und dann wieder abgezogen bis dem regier das land und hat man da noch so klausuren aus der zeit irgendwie so ich will gerne mal eine kurzgeschichte so eine reizwortgeschichte von ihm hat um ja frieden liebe menschlichkeit scheiße, ey, fuck, keine Ahnung, Mann.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Kim, das hat nicht gut funktioniert. Das war nicht dein Thema.
Da musst du noch dran arbeiten.
Ja, okay, mach ich.
Okay, auch in fliesem Deutsch, das ist auch irgendwie faszinierend.
Aber tatsächlich, jede gute und schlechte Person ist auch mal zur Schule gegangen. Es gibt lauter Leute, die haben klasse Fotos mit irgendwie dann Britney Spears. Einfach so dann, ach Britney, Britney wie Britney. Jede gute, jede ganz schlechte Person hat noch mal was Gutes gemacht. Hitler hat auch mal bestimmt eine Babykatze gerettet. Oder bei Singstar mal volle Punktzahl bekommen. Ja. Oh, was war dein Singstar-Song? Hattest du einen Lieblings-Singstar-Song? Oh, okay. Eternal Flame. Auf jeden Fall Eternal Flame. Ja. Ja. Das ist die beste Antwort. Kann man nichts machen. Kann man nichts machen. Naja, komm. Was ärgert mich jetzt mit dem Eldorado-Königreich für von Nama. Hey, das ist doch nicht so schlimm, Stefan.
Die haben das ganze Spiel gezeigt, oder?
Du hast andere Talente.
Ja, die mussten noch, die hatten dann den grünen Schleim, der dann am Ende den Ball da reingeworfen hat und dann kam Michael Jordan und ey, Leute.
Das ist ein guter Film, den muss man sich mal wieder angucken.
Der ist nicht schlecht.
Nee, war eine gute Reise.
Vor allem aber ganz im Ernst, ich weiß nicht, wer von euch in letzter Zeit mit Condor geflogen ist, aber ohne Scheiss, es ist ein sehr spezielles Bit für drei Leute im Publikum, die in den letzten Jahren mit Condor geflogen sind, aber der Sicherheitsfilm von euch geht gar nicht. Deren Sicherheitsfilm ist absolut weird, der sich einfach überlegt, wir machen sehr viele schlechte Gags, also die Queen winkt so und dann kommt Paris Hilton und dann sagen sie, für haariges Gepäck, nehmen Sie bitte die untere Gepäckablage unter ihrem Sitz und das ganze Flugzeug sagt. What, wegen dem Hund von Paris Hilton? Ja, haariges Gepäck und dann ganz am Ende sitzt da Buzz Aldrin und sagt, ein kleiner Schritt für mich, aber ein großer Schritt für ihre Flugsicherheit. Und man sagt, oh fucking hell. Und der Film ist 15 Minuten lang. Und dann wirklich, und dann sass neben mir jemand, der gesagt hat, wo sind unsere Sicherheitswesten, unsere Schwimmwesten. Und ich habe ernsthaft nachgedacht und ich wusste es nicht, weil mich haben diese Gags so abgelenkt. Du hast immer in deiner Innentasche so ein kleines Kleines-Kämmerchen, da ist die Rettungswässer. Da ist die Rettungswässer. Immer so klein. Und dann kam Charlie Chaplin und hat draufgezeigt auf so ein Exit-Zeichen. Das war alles total weird. Also das funktioniert einfach nicht. Ihr könnt so keinen Sicherheitsfilm machen. Aber das ist ja auch immer so, dass die Promis aus anderen Ländern dann in Deutschland irgendwas total Bescheuertes machen, wo sie niemanden kennt. Die machen dann in ihrem eigenen Land keine Werbung, weil das
schlecht angesehen ist, aber in Deutschland dann schon. Ich glaube, es gibt irgendwie von irgendwas
total Bescheuertem, macht Gal Gadot die Wonder Woman, die macht Werbung für irgendwie so
rein Rheinwerke oder irgendwie sowas. Das ist für einen komplett lokalen Schwachsinn einfach,
wo sie dann so, Wonder Woman bezieht ihren Strom auch von Reihenwerke. Wirklich, wirklich, tut sie das, tut sie das wirklich, wirklich, wirklich, tut sie das wirklich, nein, nein, tut sie nicht. Aber das ist das Schlimmste. Und dann bist du halt für eine Viertelstunde vor diesem Scheiß-Video und dann kommt das Ganze nochmal auf Englisch. Ja. Und es ist die absolute Hölle und das ganze flugzeug so ich hoffe wir stürzen ab und ganz im ernst wenn das irgendwer von condo hört ohne scheiß florentin schreibt euch einen besseren einspieler das wird doch geil du steuerst ein paar fliedermausgags bei ein paar fliedermausgags nicht ein paar schalke-scher-Gags, ein paar Ver-Kilmer-Gags vielleicht braucht der auch wieder Arbeit und das beste ist ist, dass Paris Hilton ist dann auch die, die dann gerade gezeigt wird, wenn die Sicherheitsmasken runterfallen. Und dann kommt dieser ganze Spruch, sicher auf Mund und Nase und danach helfen sie Kleinkindern und sie erschreckt sich, als es runterkommt. Und dann, das ist wirklich weird, dass du im Flugzeug sitzt und du siehst diesen Sicherheitsfilm und die Masken fallen runter und sie macht und man denkt so, what? Klar, aber das ist natürlich die Reaktion, die man hätte, aber alle anderen Videos machen so einen auf, es passiert gar nichts und die nehmen die und lachen dabei und machen die und helfen sie allen und Paris Hilton in dem Video hat einfach panische Angst davor. Ja, es wäre eigentlich auch mal gut so ein realistisches Video machen, so eine Sicherheitssituation, so, wir werden alle sterben, wo sind die Rutschen, wir werden alle sterben, Dann schneiden sie, legen sie eigentlich die Kehle auf einfach und jetzt einfach nur sanft die Luftmaske auf. Ja, aber dann glaube ich, würde man sich das merken, dass der nächste Sicherheitsausgang auch hinter einem sein kann. Ignorieren Sie den wild schreienden Kapitän und setzen Sie sich ruhig Ihre Sauerstoffmasken auf. Aber weiss Paris Hilton davon, dass sie in diesem Video ist? Ich glaube, es ist ein Double. Jetzt aber, Condor Rumors, neuer Hashtag. So heißt unsere neue Tour, Condor Rumors, so eine sehr spezielle Comedy-Show. Nur für Condor-Kunden. Mitarbeiter, ja. Das machen wir mal. Oh, heute Abend ist jemand da. Heute Abend hat uns jemand angetwittert. Und alle werden ganz angespann. Alle werden nervös. Jemand hat einen Lendenwirbelbruch und ist gerade auf Ibu 8000 gefühlt. Kannst du Ina, oder? Kannst du kurz mal Hallo sagen? Oh, erste Reihe, erste Reihe! Wie geht's dir? Es geht? Aber du hast schon so eine leichte Lethargie, hast du schon, so ein bisschen, ballert schon rein, oder, Ibu? Holy shit, Lendenwirbelbruch? Aber das klingt so ein bisschen, wie ist das passiert? Das klingt so ein bisschen anrüchig, Lendenwirbel. Im Erste-Hilfe-Kurs. Sehr gut. Im Erste-Hilfe-Kurs. Sehr gut. Der grösste Lacher des Abends. Wahnsinn. Aber direkt, aber ist es der beste Ort für sowas, oder nicht? Ich bin vor, du hast einen Lendenwirbelbruch angebrochen, sorry, irgendwie im Wohnzimmer und niemand ist da.
Das beste im Erste-Hilfe-Kurs.
Ja, aber eben so wie ich mich an meinen Erste-Hilfe-Kurs erinnere, will ich mit niemandem zu tun haben, der diesen Erste-Hilfe-Kurs zu tun hat.
Also du gehst da rein, lalalala.
Also, falls ihr Opfer der Arm fehlt, soll ich so, what?
Ich habe mir nichts zu tun, ich will das nicht sehen.
Aber kam dann der Instructor, kam dann an und hat gesagt, okay, dann zeigt mir, was ihr gelernt habt, und hat er es schon selber gemacht.
Vielen Dank. Ich habe damit nichts zu tun, ich will das nicht sehen. Aber kam dann der Instructor, kam dann an und hat gesagt, okay, dann zeigt mir, was ihr gelernt habt, oder hat er es schon selber gemacht? Er ist schon selber. Ist dann der erste Hilfeinstrund, oder warst du diejenige, die die Leute das beigebracht hat? Nee, ich war Teilnehmerin und es wurde auch nicht bemerkt. Es wurde, vielleicht war es ein Trick, ein geheimer Trick, dass jemand am Ende sagen würde, und einer von euch hat einen angebrochenen Lendenwirbel.
Wer hat herausgefunden, wer es war, wer hat herausgefunden, wer es war, nein, nein, nein, falsch, falsch, sei es nicht was.
Hat niemand gemerkt, ihr fallt alle durch. Oh, deshalb war es nicht leid.
Das Beste an dem Tweet war aber nicht diese Information, sondern es kann ein langer Abend werden.
Das stand in deinem Tweet.
Es kann ein langer Abend werden. Und damit haben wir jetzt offiziell auch den Titel für unsere dritte Tour. Ja, das kann ein langer Abend werden. Das stand in deinem Tweet. Das kann ein langer Abend werden. Damit haben wir jetzt offiziell auch den Titel für unsere dritte Tour.
Die Podcast-Supportur ist ein langer Abend. Das kann ein langer Abend werden 2019. Ich stehe mal auf. Ich glaube, ich hatte noch nie eine gute Zeit in einer Hängematte. Weil ich habe gerade lauter Szenarios durchgehen lassen, in denen man sich den Lendenwirbel bricht. Meine erste Assetion war Hängematte, oh, Vorsicht, Vorsicht, oh, und zack, einmal rum und direkt auf den Lendenwirbel. Ich glaube, ich hatte noch nie Spaß in der Hängematte. Nee, du hast auch danach keinen Spaß, weil du dieses Muster in dir drin hast, dieses Schachtesmuster. Das Tribalmuster einfach so, wo du dann schnell zum Tätowierer rennst und sagst, schnell, genau so, schnell.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hatte vor allem, als ich das erste Mal, ich wollte irgendwie als Kind lange Pirat werden. Klar, lange, zwei Wochen. Genau, zwei Wochen, so lange bis, und es ist immer so, ich glaube, es war immer so ein Zyklus in meiner Kindheit. Bis in der Karibik zwei rauskam und Pirat sein nicht mehr so cool war. Ja, das stimmt. Ich wollte immer irgendwas werden und meine Eltern so, oh toll, das willst du werden, wir unterstützen das, wir geben dir Informationen, wir schenken dir ein Was-is-was-Buch und diese Information hat immer dafür gesorgt, dass ich es nicht mehr werden wollte, weil Pirat und dann so, ah, du willst Pirat werden, unterstützen wir, ja, moderne Eltern sagen. Dann kommst du an den Galgen und Papa hat den Galgen im Garten gebaut. Genau, und wir machen eine Galgenparty. Guck mal, und dann habe ich so ein Buch bekommen über Schiffe und da stand drin, dass die Matrosen in Hängematten schlafen, weil die halt das Wackeln des Schiffs ausgleichen. Wirklich, die Hängematten haben dich davon ab, ein Piener zu werden. No fucking way, scheisse auf den Skelettfluch, ja, das ist mir egal. Aber Hängematten, ich habe mich dann probeweise in eine Hängematte gelegt und ach, der ist nichts für mich. Und dann habe ich tatsächlich schon im Alter von sieben Jahren den Schluss getroffen, nee, du Piraten ist nichts für mich. Das ist einfach nichts für mich. Und ich glaube, so, so, also es gibt ja viele Leute, die nicht wissen, was sie machen sollen mit ihrem Leben, die nicht wissen, welchen Beruf will ich. Und ich glaube, es ist falsch, zu überlegen, was will ich machen. Überleg einfach, was will ich nicht machen. Falsifizieren. Und dann wählt einfach einen von den 10.000 Berufen aus, die übrig bleiben. Also das ist im Grunde ganz einfach. Du guckst einfach, will ich was auf dem Schiff machen? Hängematte, nein. Will ich was mit Kriminalität machen? Nein. Und dann bleibt irgendwie auch nur noch hier so Pinzettenhersteller übrig oder so. Und dann machst du halt Pinzetten den Rest des Lebens. Aber hattest du schon mal eine schöne Zeit in der Hängematte? Immer eher im Ernst. Nee, ich habe sehr wenig Zeit meines Lebens in Hängematten verbracht.
Das obwohl ich in Mexiko bat, da waren sehr viele Hängematten, aber die waren auch meistens belegt.
Nee, das nennt man Tortilla, Stefan.
Leute lieben Hängematten, aber es ist mir auch ein Rätsel, ich weiß nicht genau warum.
Oh, wollte ich noch Lob mitteilen. Danke.
Wirklich, weil du hast mir die beste Guacamole gezeigt, die ich hier in Deutschland niemals gegessen habe. Muss man sagen, mit Tomaten, mit Tomaten, mit Zwiebeln und schön ein bisschen Limettensaft und Salz und Pfeffer. Und dann habe ich die in Mexiko gegessen und die hat fast genauso geschmeckt. Die originale Guacamole in Mexiko schmeckt genauso wie deine guac oh was ja das ist ja das ist genial das ist fucking genial wie sind die darauf gekommen einfach eine avocado mit tomate und zwiebeln salz und pfeffer zu mischen ist das das muss ein uraltes maya geheimnis sein aber tatsächlich nur die eingeborenen wissen dieses geheimnis aber in dem das nicht weiter. Aber ich war bei der Tour dabei. Aber ganz kurz, ist das die Definition von Guacamole, ist das nicht... Holy Guac. Also Holy Guac ist schon auch mit Tomaten und Zwiebeln da drin. Ja klar. Ach so. In meinem Kopf war das jetzt eine Erfindung von dir. Das Wichtige... Nicht Guacamole. Danke, dass du mir das so lange geglaubt hast. Aber tatsächlich, Kochen ist ja eigentlich nur das richtige Verhältnis rausfinden. Kochen ist nur Geduld. Kochen ist Geduld. Kochen ist trial and error. Ja, und Geduld. So, das ist mein Kochbuch. Man muss ja eigentlich immer nur genau gucken. Ah, ich mach's, ein bisschen zu viel Zwiebel, weniger Zwiebel, ah, ich mach's, bisschen zu viel Tomate, weniger Tomate oder andersrum und so und dann so kommt man langsam ran und irgendwann hat man die perfekte Guacamole, es ist halt nur viel Zeit. Zum Beispiel habe ich jetzt angefangen. Und du hast irgendwann sehr viel Guacamole, weil du sagst, okay, fuck, es sind wieder zu viele Tomaten, mehr zu viel. Ja, ja, das stimmt. Das ist so das Cornflakes, Milchkuchen. Dann bist du wieder bei Rewe und er sagt schon die gleiche Sache wie das letzte Mal.
Mir hat gleich Avocados zu haben.
Zum Ende hast du vier Tonnen Kellogg's gegessen.
Aber ich habe jetzt noch angefangen, ähm, wie sag ich das, na ja, ich habe angefangen,
Bananentee zu trinken.
Und auch da das Verhältnis Bananentee.
Bananentee. Drei Fragen. Banane. Lass mich, ja, auf den ersten Blick Banane geil, Banane ist eine feine Sache, das Problem an der Banane ist das Essen, ja das ist nicht so meins. Banane essen, das klingt,, als ob du auf der Suche nach einer Lösung für ein Problem bist, was nicht existiert. Na, ich dachte mir, eigentlich ist es ja genial, weil eigentlich willst du ja, ich habe tatsächlich mein Leben lang, versuche ich eine kreative Abnehm-Methode zu finden, mir zu überlegen, ich will nicht laufen, ich will nicht nicht bewegen, ich will im Bett liegen und machen, was ich will, so, wie kann ich trotzdem nicht richtig fett werden? So, und dann dachte ich mir immer so, als Kind habe ich ohne Witz lange damit geliebäugelt, Essen zu essen, aber nicht runterzuschlucken. Und tatsächlich ein wirklich grosser Teil, es waren wirklich intensiv zwei Wochen, wo ich wirklich so vorm Snickers saß und dachte, so, du oder ich, mein Lieber, jetzt, und dann wirklich essen und so, ist das gut, ist das lecker, ist das lecker, aber ich muss es ja nicht schlucken. Aber im Endeffekt ist es nicht dasselbe, es funktioniert einfach nicht. Es funktioniert einfach nicht. Manche Leute sind weitergegangen und mir kommt der Finger in den Mund und dann schlucken sie an wenigstens. Oder irgendwann habe ich mir auch gedacht, reicht nicht riechen. Reicht nicht einfach riechen. Das Thema hatten wir schon mal. Riechen und schmecken sind sehr nah beieinander. Sind sehr nah beieinander. Da habe ich zum Beispiel so einen Hund, der kann super gut riechen. Also hat er dann auch mehr Freude am Riechen? Also hat er, weil ich meine, Geschmacksnerven sind ja nur Nerven sowie Riechnerven. Das ist ja eigentlich nur, da hängt irgend so einen Blitz im Gehirn. Ein G-Spot. So, und wenn du deine Blitze jetzt unter Kontrolle hast, dann ist es ja, vielleicht kannst du dein Gehirn täuschen, dass es Riechen genauso gut ist wie Essen, wenn du es einfach nur trainierst. Ich erspare euch viel Zeit, es klappt nicht. Es klappt nicht. Wenn du über so einer Dose Pringels bist und die inhalierst, irgendwann hast du sie auch gegessen. Es funktioniert nicht. Schritt drei, Tee, weil Tee ermöglicht es dir, Dinge zu schmecken,
auch im Mund, ohne sie zu essen. Ja, du haust irgendwas in kochendes Wasser, das nimmt dann
den Geschmack, aber nicht die Kalorien, die Kalorien bleiben zuhause. So heißt mein Kochbuch. Die Kalorien bleiben zuhause. Die Kalorien können zuhause bleiben. Ja, genau. Die Kalorien können zuhause bleiben. Ja, genau. Die Kalorien können zuhause. Ey, Leute, nach der Show, ich signiere euch die Bücher. Und dann kommt der Geschmack raus und du tust dann den Klops weg und dann trinkst du das Ganze. Ganz kurz, heisst wenn ich jetzt so eine Butter, so ein schönes Pfund Butter in kochendes Wasser mache, dann bleiben die Kalorien zuhause, wenn ich das dann trinke. Ja, Butter ist jetzt ein schlechtes, du müsstest Butter in so ein Filter reintun. Das erste, was du sagst, war ein schlechtes Beispiel. Naja, gut, die ersten vier sind immer ein schlechtes Beispiel, das weiß jeder. Du müsstest die Butter eigentlich in den Filter tun, weil sonst kommt die Butter heraus. Aber was bleibt dann über am Ende? Das weiss niemand. Wie gross sind Kalorien? Weil Kalorien bleiben ja nicht im Filter. Kalorien sind klitzeklein, oder? Tic Tac ist eine Kalorie. Haben die mal gesagt, die haben immer Werbung damit gemacht, dass Tic Tac eine Kalorie hat. Und seitdem hat jede Kalorie für mich die Grösse eines Tic Tacs. Ja, und ich muss nur nachrechnen, okay.
Das Falsches, das kann ich euch verraten. Ich esse 470 Tic Tacs, also sind das grob. Aber ich kann am Tag, habe ich mal ausgerechnet, am Tag muss ich 3500 Kit Cats, Tic Tacs. Da war der Fehler. Was? Deswegen. Deswegen die 100 Kilo. Moment. Tic Tacs, nicht Kit Kats. Nicht Kit Kats haben nur eine Kalorie. Ich wusste, die 100 Kilo müssen irgendwoher kommen. Aber was, 3000 Kalorien willst du aufnehmen? Ja, oder 2000. 3000, viel zu viel. Vielleicht wenn man Sport macht und vielleicht habe ich aber auch, bin ich in der Zeile verrutscht, weil ich es wollte, wo man, wenn man Muskeln aufbauen will, da muss man ein bisschen mehr. Ja, aber du warst bei Kilojoule, was zur Hölle auch immer Kilojoule sind. Hektopascal, okay. Also wirklich, ne, aber wenn sich eines nicht durchsetzt, dann Kilojoule, das immer Kalorien-Schrägstich Kilojoule und du denkst dir so, nice try, komm schon. Wir wissen alle, dass es sich nicht durchsetzt, niemand mag Kilojoule. Joule, das kannst du auch Kiloampere, was ist das? Aber wir müssen es kurz noch machen. Bananentee ist simpel. Du nimmst kochendes Wasser, ballerst eine Banane rein, lässt das so ziehen. Bananen haben nicht viel Kalorien, ich verstehe. Doch, Bananen haben sehr viel Kalorien, du hast keine Ahnung von Ernährung. Gut, okay. Du hast überhaupt keine Ahnung von Ernährung. Lies meine Bücher, bevor du hier mit mir über Ernährung redest. Okay, Recherche. Und interessanterweise wird die Banane, und das ist verrückt, die Banane altert, die wird schwarz. So wie eine Banane schwarz wird, wenn sie lange herumliegt. Das kannst du beschleunigen durch heißes Wasser. Und dann, das Pferd meldet sich wieder zu Wort. Das Ernährungspferd, klipp, klapp, keine Kohlenhydrate. Lass mir nichts mit dem Pferd sagen. Du haust mit Fakten um dich und die Reaktion ist Realität. Einstein sagt eh gleich MZH2. Okay, Steini. Auf jeden Fall habe ich den Bananentee gemacht, Banane raus und dann den Tee getrunken und es hat tatsächlich nach Banane geschmeckt. Aber ich hatte dann diese ausgelaugte Banane vor mir und dachte mir, wenn der Bananengeschmack jetzt im Wasser ist, ist dann der Wassergeschmack in... Wo ist... Was ist jetzt in der Banane drin? Was ist hier los? Und ich habe mich nicht getraut, sie zu essen, weil ich war nicht bereit. Weil dann steht immer vor, du isst eine Banane, die nach nichts schmeckt. Gruselig. Super gruselig. Aber bitte? Sorry, ganz kurz. Die schlechten Plätze wollen gleichzeitig reden. Nochmal, ja, wir haben eine äusserst ungewöhnlich, eine Publikumsfrage, ja, bitteschön.
Ja, gut, dass du fragst, mit Schale, mit Schale.
Mit Schale hast du das so reingeballert? Ja, aber da krabbeln doch alle ran.
Ja, Freunde, die Schale ist das Beste, was?
Nein, ich lasse mir auch, also so.
Und das Problem ist, interessanterweise, stopp, stopp, stopp, setzt euch bitte hin, setzt euch bitte hin, setzt euch bitte hin, setzt euch hin.
Okay, ich dachte, es ist an dem Punkt, wo wir den Massenmord an Nordkorea leugnen, nein, es ist der Punkt, wo wir Bananen mit Schale in den Tochtock werfen, das ist der Punkt, wo Leute sagen, wow, okay, ich höre hier nur zu, aber ich habe jetzt das Bedürfnis, reinzurufen. Ja, nein, die Sache ist die generelle Rezepte für Bananentee findet man nicht auf chefkoch.de, findet man nicht in der Enzyklopädie der Umtees. Das ist mittlerweile so ein Verschwörungstheoretiker-Duktus. Das findet man nicht da. Nirgendwo finde ich Beweise dafür. Sondern der einzige Ort, an dem man Rezepte für Bananentees findet, ist youtube.com. Oder de. Oder es. Und das Problem, und da gibt es ein geniales Video, und das könnt ihr gerne selber suchen, und zwar das Video heißt, Koche eine Banane mit abgeschnittenen Enten zehn Minuten lang in Wasser. So heisst das Video.
Das ist der Titel des Videos. Also wirklich so Anti-Clickbait, so wirklich liess den Titel, damit du das Video nicht anschauen musst. Okay, und dann klickst du es wieder. Genau wie das Video Mann will furzen, kackt aber, wo man sagt, du verrätst alles. Alles!
Alles!
Mann will furzen, kackt aber!
Aber ich habe das Video noch nie gesehen. Warum? Das ist die einfache Regel, die Pointe nicht verraten. Ja, aber tatsächlich, ich habe mir das Video trotzdem noch angeguckt und da hat mir jemand erklärt, ja pass auf, du musst eine Banane nehmen, die Enten abschneiden und dann zehn Minuten lang in Wasser kochen.
Ist ja auch wirklich. Aber tatsächlich, ich hatte dieselbe Denken wie du, Laura, sag ich jetzt einfach mal. Boah, wenn das gestimmt hätte, holy schmoly. Ich hatte die gleiche Intuition wie Laura und dachte mir, Moment mal, wenn ich die Banane reintue, dann kommt ja das Wasser gar nicht an die Banane ran. Aber dafür schneidet man Anfang und Ende ab, damit wie in so einer Pipeline das Wasser einmal durch die ganze Banane durchgeht, links und rechts den Geschmack mitnehmen, so wirklich die Greifen rein. Ja, überall. Die haben nur so eine Minute Zeit, wie in dieser Toys-A-As-Super-RTL-Werbung, wo man schnell alle eine Minute und so ballert das kochende Wasser durch die Banane, nimmt sich links und rechts zu spieles Nimmt sich erst die Fahrräder und man denkt, Leute, wer braucht denn vier Fahrräder? Oder fahrt zumindest mit den Fahrrädern schneller durch den Markt. Goldbarren, scheiss drauf, wir machen hier noch fünf Dreiräder einfach. Fahrt bis zum Ende und nimmt die Wii-Spiele. Ja, und so Banane also durch, alles durch die Banane durch, aber ich habe die Banane nicht gegessen, die Banane war pechschwarz, aber der Bananentee hat eigentlich ganz gut geschmeckt und es ist anscheinend auch ein, hat eine einschläfende Wirkung, Bananentee. Also das ist der Grund, warum ihr jetzt eingeschlafen seid, weil Bananentee hat irgendwie so Zeug drin, Opium oder irgendwie sowas. Melatonin vielleicht. Morphium, so baut man Morphium ab. Ne, wie heißt das? Chloroform. Chloroform. Nein, das war ein Spaß, das wird da nicht drin sein. Habe ich nie bestellt. Deswegen hat einschläfernde Wirkung und deswegen kann ich euch auch gar nicht sagen, ob der gut geschmeckt hat oder nicht, weil ich bin recht schnell eingeschlafen und das ist dann immer so das Problem, so hat der gut geschmeckt? Ich weiß es nicht, ich kann es dir nicht sagen. Vielleicht hat der Typ sich das Video gemacht, um sich danach daran erinnern zu können, ob es gut geschmeckt hat, weil es immer passiert, dass er so schnell einschläft. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist auch das Gruseligste, was jemals bei Reddit passiert ist meiner Meinung nach und da passiert viel gruseliges Zeug jeden Tag bei Reddit. Und tatsächlich hat da jemand die Internet-Community um Hilfe gebeten, weil er jeden Tag, ups, weil jeden Tag, du hast übrigens noch sechs Flaschen, ne, also nebenbei. Ja, ich wollte nur noch mal sicher gehen, weil jeden Tag hat er das Post-it in seiner Wohnung gefunden. Und er kann sich daran nicht erinnern, dass er die aufgehangen hat oder dass ein anderer Mensch Zugang zu seiner Wohnung hat. Der Herr war alleine lebend, teilweise auch einfach, er ist abends ins Bett gegangen und morgens hat er ein Post-it irgendwo gefunden, mit weirden Dingen drauf, Dinge, die nur er wissen konnte. Und dann hat irgendein Reddit-User, viele haben einfach nur Späße gemacht, aber dann einen Reddit-User hat herausgefunden, wahrscheinlich hast du eine Kohlenmonoxid-Vergiftung, Ir scheint bei dir nicht in Ordnung zu sein und deswegen schreibst du dir selber, um dich daran zu erinnern zu können, was passiert ist und an was du mal gedacht hast und was du selber weißt, gibst dir für deine Zukunft Tipps, so Memento-mässig, nur ohne die Titus. Wie ist es, wie ich habe einen Kohlenmonoxid-Lag, bitte, bitte ändert das, oder so, ich kann mir das nicht erklären. Was ist hier passiert, was geht hier vor sich? Und dann hat er wirklich Leute geholt, die das gecheckt haben, und tatsächlich war die Konzentration von, ich nage mich nicht drauf fest, das ist ein wissenschaftliches Kram. Aber das hatten wir doch schon mal, dass uns irgendwo, ich glaube das war bei Rocket Beans TV, dass wir irgendwie über Kohlenmonoxid-Vergiftung gesprochen haben, weil irgendeine Zuschauerin auch immer irgendwie eingeschlafen ist oder immer schwindelig war und da hat auch jemand geschrieben, ja, ich habe jetzt mal einen Test gemacht bei mir und ich habe auch Kohlenmonoxid erhöht in meiner Wohnung. Anscheinend kommt das häufiger vor. Vielleicht lässt sich jede religiöse Erfahrung irgendwie einfach durch Kohlenmonoxid erklären oder irgendwie jedes UFO oder sowas, einfach dadurch, du hattest halt Kohlenmonoxid irgendwie im Blut. Jedes UFO lässt sich durch Kohlenmonoxid erklären. So ist mein nächstes Buch, glaube ich. Auch muss man nicht mehr lesen. Direkt indexiert auch. Kohlenmonoxid. Schaut auch an unseren Tontechniker, der uns Fakten über Ufos schicken will, weil man offensichtlich dachte, dass wir hier einen Vortrag über Ufos halten. Und es tut mir ein bisschen leid, dass wir bislang nicht so viel über Ufos gesprochen haben. Es tut mir leid, es tut mir leid. Man ist manchmal im Flow drin und dann kommt man nicht zu dem, was man eigentlich sagen wollte. Sorry. Ich habe mal ein UFO gesehen in Dänemark, wo man sich auch fragt. Ich habe viele Städte besichtigt, wo man sagen könnte, okay, für Aliens potenziell interessant, Rom, New York, warum muss ich am Strand in Dänemark auf der Insel Röm, warum soll ich da Aliens finden? Vielleicht heißt das irgendwas Beleidigendes in der Aliensprache. Ja, selber auch Römmelder, fragen wir zwei Inman, fick dich! Ja, vielleicht. Aber wie sah es aus, kannst du es beschreiben? Es war zu... so, wie erkläre ich das, dass ich nicht wie ein Vollidiot rüberkomme? Und zwar war das ein weisser Punkt am Himmel und es war so weit weg, dass man... War es ein heller Punkt? Ja, nee, es war auch ganz hell, muss ich dazu sagen. Ein heller Punkt am Himmel? Tageszeit war vielleicht so 13 Uhr mittags. Okay, wir überlegen, ein heller Punkt am Himmel um 13 Uhr mittags. Genau, und der ist so ruckartig geflogen. Wirst du gerade Sonne? Wolltest du darauf hinaus? Ich wollte es nicht sagen, du willst nicht aussehen wie ein Vollidiot. Und dann ist das ruckartig geflogen. Wirst du gerade Sonne? Wolltest du darauf hinaus? Ich wollte es nicht sagen. Du willst nicht aussehen wie ein Vollidiot.
Und dann ist es ruckartig geflogen.
Und zwar so schnell, dass man sagen konnte, das ist kein Flugzeug, weil dafür war es auch zu weit weg.
Und die Form war kreisförmig.
Wahrscheinlich war es was anderes.
Es war sehr wahrscheinlich was anderes.
Manchmal hat man ja auch so Krössl im Auge.
Ja, ja, Fussel, Augenfussel.
Und dann denkt man sich, wo, ich glaube, das es schon wieder. Ich habe viel Augenfussel. Das ist doch, weil die Hornhaut stirbt. Sagt Google. Das wollte ich auch ganz sagen. Ist es nicht, dass irgendwie das Saft, in dem das Auge schwimmt, so Klumpen hat und dass sich dann da irgendwie so... Mann ey, ey, wozu gucke ich denn die ganzen fucking Dokus, wenn ich mir nichts merken kann? Jetzt habe ich ein für alle Mal alles über das Auge gelernt, zwei Wochen später keine Ahnung. Genau wie diese, wir haben ja wirklich damals bei guter Arbeit, wir hätten Skate schreiben sollen, wir haben stattdessen über Chaos Theorie eine lange Dokureihe im Internet angeguckt. Und ich dachte zwischenzeitlich, das sind so sieben Videos bei YouTube, müssen wir mal verlinken, die sind unglaublich gut. Und man denkt bei sechs, man hat irgendwie so eine Epiphanie und jetzt habe ich das verstanden. Jetzt habe ich das Wort Epiphanie gelernt und ich habe Chaos-Theorie verstanden. Hattest du das auch bei diesem Gucken, als du kurz denkst, ah okay, klar, deswegen funktioniert die Welt so wie sie funktioniert und dann kaum ist das letzte Video vorbei, hast du alles wieder vergessen. Alles weg. Liegt das an so einem Schulsystem, wo man kurze Zeit kritisch zu werden? Nee, es liegt an Kohlenmonoxid tatsächlich, das ist das Problem. Die grosse Kohlenmonoxid. Vielleicht ist einfach die Welt zu... Ist das dieser Klimawandel, von dem man so viel hört, dass man so viel Kohlenmonoxid...
Also dieses fucking Kohlenoxid hat's echt verhauen, ey, wirklich. Ganz schlechte PR.
Kohlenmonoxid ist nicht gut, Kohlendioxid ist nicht gut.
Xide sind nicht gut.
Ich will nicht wissen, was Kohlentrioxid so im Schilde führt.
Ich hab meine Augen auf dich, mein Lieber. Da kommt auch noch irgendwas raus.
Nee, allgemein, Xide sind nicht gut, glaub ich. Nimm mir ein gutes Xid. Keine guten Xids. Na, jetzt hast du mich. Xid? Diese Bad? Die grossen Impro-Regeln, immer Ja und zu sagen. Und dann kommt der Typ, mit dem du auf die Bühne musst und er sagt, nimm mir noch einen Xid. Die Regel ist eigentlich bei Impro immer, ja, jetzt hast du mich. Ab hier weise ich nicht mehr weiter. Xit. Das ist gut. Die Oxid-Lobby ist im Haus. Vielleicht funktioniert Chemie auch nicht so, dass man sagt, das ist gut und das ist schlecht. Vielleicht ist Chemie komplexer. Du meinst, dass so Begriffe wie gut und schlecht eigentlich nur menschliche Konstrukte sind, um sich in der Welt zu orientieren, die mit der eigentlichen Natur gar nichts zu tun haben? Nein. Ach so, ich weiß nicht. Ist ein langer Abend geworden für dich, ne?
Aber musst du dich konzentrieren, die Augen noch aufzuhalten, oder geht's?
Ibo 800.
Gibt's mehr als Ibo 800?
Ja.
Mehr, mehr, mehr.
Wir sprechen 800, Freunde.
Fragen mich mal.
Ich hatte noch nie so krasse Schmerzen, dass ich gesagt habe, jetzt brauche ich irgendwas dagegen. Ich habe das, glaube ich, angenehmste Leben der Welt. Ja, sagt der Mann, der gerade auf der Bühne steht, ein bisschen rumblödelt und sagt, ich habe noch nie Schmerzen. Ja, ich lebe in so einer Marshmallow-Welt, wo einfach alles so weich um mich ist. Und ich noch nie Schmerzen, vielleicht hatte ich schon mal Schmerzen, die angemessen waren, aber ich habe einfach, ich habe vielleicht genau wie bei den Augen, weiß ich nicht, dass jetzt der Punkt ist, zu viel Schmerz zu haben. Das einzige, worauf ich noch warte, ist, dass mein Arzt immer gesagt hat, ja, pass mal auf, Sie sind viel zu fett. Das hat er genau so gesagt, genau diesem Stimmbrecher sind viel zu fett, viel, viel, viel zu fett.
Also Herr Wäld, jetzt lassen Sie, wie soll ich es formulieren jetzt, der medizinische Fachbegriff ist fette Sau.
Dann dreht er seine Checkliste um, auf der er die ganze Zeit geschrieben hat und es ist einfach nur Fetty Mac, fett, fett. Ja, und er hat gesagt, ja, pass auf, ja, Gallensteine sind ein Thema, sie werden irgendwann in den nächsten Tagen einen Messerstichartigen Schmerz spüren und das ist dann das Signal, dass ihre Gallensteine sich irgendwo eingeklemmt haben. Tschau! Tschüss! So messerstichartige, was, was? Aber auch dann, woher weise ich, dass der Schmerz messerstichartig ist? Das klingt vor allem wie eine Bedrohung. Es klingt wie eine Bedrohung. Wenn du jetzt nicht abnimmst, dann wirst du morgen messerstichartige Schmerzen.
Ich will nicht näher auf diese Schmerzen eingehen, aber sie sind messerstichartig.
Wie fühlt sich das an von einem Messergeschoss? Also wirklich, kann man sich das vorstellen?
Spielt man da überhaupt viel oder ist es dann nicht so? Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich glaube, irgendwann knickt es doch so zu Überlebenskampf, da kann man doch noch nicht sagen, aua, aua, aua.
Sondern irgendwann wirst du wahrscheinlich dann so viel Adrenalin haben, dass du sagst, fuck it, jetzt muss ich, jetzt, nein, das meint jetzt noch so ein Messer, ah, du bist Adrenalin-Chunky, hier, bitteschön, hohi shit, gestern, ich habe gestern versucht zu joggen und ich wusste, es ist schlecht und meine Kondition besteht, also ich war, davor waravor im Queen-Film, hatte nicht so viel damit zu tun, ausser dass ich dachte, okay, jetzt höre ich einen geilen Queen-Song, Keep Yourself Alive, und dachte mir, okay, ich halte mich immer am Leben, ich gehe immer eine Runde joggen. So, aber irgendwann hat der Film seine Bedeutung geändert, denn das war der Song, den ich angemacht habe, als ich losgelaufen bin. Der Song ist, sagen wir mal, vier Minuten lang. Am Ende des Songs hatte ich einen Hustenanfall. Man muss sich das vorstellen, ich wohne auf der anderen Seite des Rheins in Köln, wo nicht der Dom steht, auf der anderen Seite. Und die Joggingstrecke ist eigentlich total geil, die ist eigentlich total kurz auch. Ich gehe über die Brücke und komme zurück. Und ich wohne an der Brücke, es ist wirklich nur einmal über den Rhein. Und ich habe es bis zum anderen Ufer geschafft und dann nicht weiter, weil ich habe plötzlich meine Lunge zusammengezogen, es war auch sehr kalt und ich habe einfach husten müssen die ganze Zeit. Und dann kamen mir so Familien entgegen, die vom Weihnachtsmarkt kamen und dann kamen mir so ganz viele Kinder entgegen mit so grossen Zuckerwatte-Dingern, die grösser waren als die Kinder selbst. Und ich sah mir beim Leben zu und dachte mir, das Leben will ich leben und nicht das, was ich gerade mache und bin losgelaufen und dann kamen die mir entgegen und ich wollte denen nicht den Gefallen tun, dass ich jetzt vorne den Abbreche zu laufen. Hab aber schon gemerkt, das wird heute nichts mehr und bin auch weiter gelaufen und das war wahrscheinlich der Fehler.
Und ich glaube, es ist wirklich Asthma. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich, und da habe ich nämlich gelesen, weil es wurde schon mal diagnostiziert bei mir und dann irgendwann war es nicht mehr so ein Riesenthema, weil ich nicht mehr viel Sport gemacht habe einfach. Aber dann steht da, Asthma tritt auf, wenn man Sport macht, es wird aber schlechter, wenn man keinen Sport macht. Das ist, das muss ich dann lesen. Aber ich dachte mir, was ist das für eine Abwehrspirale aus der fucking Hölle? Ja.
Ich komme da nicht mehr raus jetzt. Und es war wirklich schlimm und dann musste ich ganz doll husten, hat sich so komischer Schleim gebildet, es war wirklich komisch und dann bin ich wieder zurückgegangen und dann sind mir wirklich Familien entgegengekommen, die mich gesehen haben, wie ich über die Brücke losglaupt, die habe ich überholt und ich muss mir vorstellen, zwei Minuten später sahen die klinisch toten, 24-jährigen, der auf der anderen Seite wieder zurückgeht. Aber da sind keine Minuten vergangen. Ich bin einfach rüber über die Brücke und dann wieder zurück. Und die sind gegangen, wurden plötzlich überholt, langsam, von einem langsamen georgenden Typen und dann kam der paar Minuten später gehend und hustend auf der anderen Seite wieder zurück. Was haben die sich gedacht? Der war so mit der Zuckerwatte, wir haben alles richtig gemacht. Wir haben alles richtig gemacht. Wir hatten einen guten Abend. Aber das ist immer so das Problem, wenn man nur einen coolen Song hat. Ich kenne das auch, ich bin ja auch mal eine Zeit lang gejoggt. Du hast dann einen coolen Song und denkst dir, höre ich den jetzt einfach zweimal für meine achtminütige Joggingtour oder höre ich nach einem auf oder habe ich so auf halber Geschwindigkeit oder so. Aber wie hast du das denn gemacht, wie hast du denn damals, als du so abgenommen hast, hast du bisher vor allem gejoggt? Im Stockdunklen. Punkt eins, niemand sollte mich sehen. Das war auch so bei Widerplanen. Ja, aber du joggst sogar die Rheinbrücke. Also wirklich, ich habe gefragt, ob die Lichter ausmachen können, und dann haben wir gesagt, nein, sie sind verrückt. Können die Schlösser abhängen, bitte, können die alle weg? Nein. Und dann hast du langsam angefangen oder bist du dabei? Ja, ich habe langsam angefangen. Ich habe total langsam angefangen. Aber wie langsam? Was ist langsam angefangen? Ja, ich glaube, ich habe angefangen mit, ich glaube, der Fachbegriff dafür ist Spazierengehen. Nur kurze Illustration, das sieht so aus. Gegangen. Einfach normal gegangen. Gegangen. Und dann bist du getrabt. Und dann irgendwann, und dann hatte ich so eine quadratische Bahn und dann dachte ich mir immer so, okay, eine Woche lang nur spazieren gehen den Weg.
Ich war richtig fett, konnte überhaupt nicht laufen.
Wirklich? Spazieren gehen war dann am Anfang.
War am Anfang. Einfach 60 Minuten spazieren gehen ist schon mal ein Anfang.
Und dann machst du 60 Minuten spazieren gehen und dann sagst du halt einfach, okay, den einen Teil dieser Quadratstrecke, den laufe ich. Drei Teile spazieren, ein Teil laufen. So, das machst du dann auch eine Woche. Drei Teile spazieren, ein Teil laufen. Und dann nächste Woche sagst du, zwei Teile laufen, zwei Teile spazieren gehen. Und so arbeitet es sich irgendwann hoch, bis du alles läufst, dann schneller, dann zweimal und so, arbeitet es sich halt irgendwie hoch. Und dann funktioniert es auch einigermaßen. Du brauchst halt viel Zeit einfach, dass du das auch langfristig machen kannst. Und es ist halt auch gut, wenn du es jeden Tag machen kannst, wenn du keinen Job hast zum Beispiel, dann kannst du das gut machen oder deine WoW-Gilte dich rausgeschmissen hat. Und deswegen, dann kannst du es gut machen. Aber wirklich meine erste Priorität war, von niemandem gesehen werden. Deswegen war ich teilweise auch im Tiergarten in Berlin und es gibt so eine Phase im Jahr, wo der Tiergarten in Berlin abgezäunt ist, mit so Bauzaunen.
Ja, das heißt glaube ich nicht reingehen. Ja, ich dachte mir nämlich so, jeder Zaun heißt entweder nicht rein oder nicht raus. Welche Art von Zaun ist das jetzt? Ist es ein Nicht-Rein-Zaun oder ist es ein Nicht-Raus-Zaun?
Weil in einem Tierpark sind Tiere und dann dachte ich, die wollen, dass die Tiere nicht rausgehen, weil die sonst überfahren werden von Mofa-Fahrern oder anderen Autofahrern. Und dann dachte ich mir, ah, ich bin kein Tier. Ich liebe diese Unruhe, die sich immer so langsam breit macht. Mofa, können wir ihm noch folgen? Auf jeden Fall glaube ich, habe ich da irgendwie das gesamte Ökosystem kaputt gemacht. Aber letztens dachte ich mir, ich laufe am schnellsten, wenn mir jemand die Tür aufhält. Also wenn jemand so zehn Meter weit weg ist und jemand mir die Tür aufhält und ich wirklich so Usain Bolt einfach so zack Leute, jetzt geht's los. Ich dachte mir, könnte man das nicht machen, so in Fitnessstudios bei so Laufbändern, dass man da da immer so dem Trainer vorsteht und so den die Tür aufmacht und so einen wartenden, genervten Blick und so, okay, ja, komme, einfach und dann die ganze Zeit, 90 Minuten lang rennt der Tür. Wie lange hältst du für jemanden die Tür auf? Oft unangenehm, weil ich habe diese strenge
acht Sekunden Regel und wenn da jemand, wenn da wirklich die Oma von mir oben drüber, Oma Meier, kommt ein bisschen zu spät, dann knallt die Tür halt leider voll zu.
Weil irgendwann ist es auch unangenehm, da zu stehen. Ich finde, man sollte nicht verlangen, dass jemand die Tür aufhält, wenn man noch so lange braucht.
Letztens hat jemand mir die Tür aufgehalten, Tür aufgehalten und ich war super weit weg, ich dachte mir einfach, du Arschloch.
Tür aufgehalten, und dann guckt er, und dann gibt es ja drei Phasen, erst mal gucken, dann weggucken. Also wenn man schon wirklich merkt, okay, dann auf die Uhr gucken, sorry, sorry gerade, dass ich zwei Beine habe und dann kam der absolute Arschloch-Move, ich weiss nicht, ob ihr den schon jemand erlebt habt, Fuss, Fuss vor die Tür. Also wo ihr denkt, das ist eine längere Geschichte jetzt. Das ist jetzt länger. Fuss vor die Tür. Dann kommt die Schuhe ausziehen und Schuhe reinstellen, damit die Tür nicht im Schloss fällt. Türstopper kaufen bei Obi, auspacken, ranmachen und ich, einfach schrecklich. Aber das ist wirklich, das ist die Gründe. Es gibt ja so Apps, die dir so aufs Ohr sagen, so ein Zombie ist hinter dir, lauf weg, damit du schnell läufst. Es gibt wirklich so Zombie-Apps, irgendein Politiker, Boris, Peter Tauber, richtig, fuck, ich bin so schlecht mit so Namen. Ist gut, alles gut. Ja, aber der hat diese App benutzt, damit er besser laufen kann. Da heisst du, die Zombies sind jetzt hinter dir, sie sind 100 Meter entfernt. Aber das ist nicht der erste Gang, den man hat bei einer Zombie-Akabalebse. Jetzt erst mal eine Runde Joggen gehen. Ja, jetzt erst mal irgendwie schön Katie Melua aufs Ohr, nochmal irgendwie mit dem Park. Warum, man würde doch erst mal die Fenster zumachen. Vor allem Zombies. Man würde doch keinen Sport machen. Zombies sind das Langsamste, was es gibt. Also wirklich die Motivation vor Zombies weglaufen kann nicht so. Also rückwärts vor Zombies weglaufen, das ist eine Herausforderung. Das gebe ich dir. Aber vorwärts, das kriegt man hin. Das sind so ein Zombie-Apokalypse und die Jogger überleben alle. Stell dir eine Welt vor, in der nur Jogger überleben. Einfach nur diese ganzen arroganten Arschlöcher, die weder anfangen, die weder Urlaub joggen. Wenn man in den Urlaub f, in einem schönen Urlaubsauto, man sieht den ersten Jogger und man denkt, oh fuck you, ey, ganz so Urlaub ruiniert. Warum joggt man? Ich kann es mir auch nicht erklären, wie ich es damals geschafft habe zu joggen. Ich würde es nie wieder machen und ich werde es nie wieder machen, das war die schrecklichste Zeit meines Lebens. Aber aus irgendeinem Grund hat es... Fuck, du hast mich gerade so gut motiviert, weil ich dachte, dieses Quadrat, das klingt gut und erst eine Seite, eine andere Seite und dann darf danach als Motivationstrainer nicht kommen, das war die furchtbare Zeit meines Lebens.
Ich habe es geschafft, es ist machbar, aber es ist dann die furchtbare Zeit deines Lebens.
Ich habe eine andere Art des Abnehmens gefunden, Bananentee.
Immer wenn du dir denkst, das würde ich gerade gerne essen, trink einen Bananentee und du wachst neun Stunden später auf in irgendeiner Toilette, in irgendeinem Club in Berlin und denkst du, wow, ich habe es nicht gegessen. Wieder 4000 Kilojoule gespart. Nice. Yes. Ach ja. Stefan, du wirst nicht mehr laufen. Wer sagt es von uns? Du wirst nicht mehr laufen. Wer bringt die böse Kunde rüber, dass du nicht mehr laufst? Fast, dass wir jetzt
leider am Ende angekommen sind.
Leute, wer schafft es, wer tut es von uns?
Ihr wart ein ganz fantastisches Publikum.
Vielen Dank an Laura für ihren Einruf.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Dankeschön, aus dein Applaus, Laura.
Das war deine Show.
Und es war deine Show.
Ich hoffe, der Schmerz war erträglich.
Alles Gute für deine Wirbel. Du hast es überlebt. Ansonsten sind wir jetzt gleich noch beim Merch-Shop.
Auf jeden Fall, wir sagen noch mal kurz Hallo.
Falls ihr Stefan Tietze mal riechen wollt, falls ihr mal wissen wollt, wie er riecht.
Don't.
Trefft uns gleich am Merch-Shop, wo wir natürlich auch die T-Shirts und Poster kaufen können und alles weiter. Ansonsten vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen, vielen Dank Empore.
Wir heben ab, wir heben ab, heben ab.
Yes, danke schön. Vielen Dank, Herr Chore. Wir heben ab. Macht's gut. Heben ab. Heben ab. Yes.
Dankeschön.
Macht's gut.
Ciao, wir sehen uns.
Danke.